Jupp Nehl hat über 200 Bundesligaspiele gemacht für Bochum und für Leverkusen und selbst wenn ihr das nicht mitbekommen habt, dann seid ihr seine Arbeit schon mal über den Weg gelaufen. Denn ich weiß, ihr Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr habt schon mal Bundesliga geguckt und dann habt ihr nämlich seine Arbeit mitverfolgen können. Jupp Nehl hat nämlich nach seiner Karriere als Profifußballer eine bei der Sportcast gemacht. Das ist die Firma, die alle Bilder zur Bundesliga produziert und noch viel mehr. Wir haben darüber gesprochen, über seinen Weg, wie das eigentlich ging, dass er zur Sportcast kam und was das eigentlich bedeutet und wie jetzt sein Alltag aussieht. Es gibt nicht allzu viele Interviews mit ihm, deswegen freue ich mich sehr, dass er sich Zeit genommen hat für den Rasenfunk. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß. Wir hören den Rasenfunk.
Das selbe Muster wie beim Ausgleich, das ist ja der selbe Angriff. Ups, da haben wir uns verstanden, die haben einfach noch mal das Tor eingespielt. Mach deine Scheißkamera aus.
Das Tribünengespräch. Also Herr Nehl, es freut mich sehr, dass das geklappt hat. Mich würde interessieren, wenn Sie zu einem Fußballspiel vor Ort im Stadion gehen, wo zieht Sie es aktuell eher hin? Immer noch in den Kabinentrakt oder eher zum TV-Combound, wo die Trucks stehen?
Also wenn ich ins Stadion fahre, dann fahre ich natürlich zunächst mal, oder gehe ich zunächst mal zum Übergestellplatz, um mal allen Leuten guten Tag zu sagen und mal zu hören, wie die Stimmung ist und so weiter. Und dann gehe ich aber auch relativ zügig dann durch, nicht durch den Kabinentrakt, aber durch die Mix-Zonen und die unteren Bereiche, um dann auch kurz auf den Platz zu gehen. Da sind meistens dann die Lizenznehmer, denen man dann auch mal guten Tag sagt, ohne dass man jetzt stört oder irgendwas rein platzt. Also insofern, ich bin in erster Linie dann da für die Produktion, um mir das anzuschauen. Aber natürlich gehe ich dann auch auf die Tribüne oder auf die Press-Tribüne, um mir das Spiel anzuschauen. Dafür ist die Verbundenheit zum Fußball natürlich immer noch zu groß.
Ich meine, sie haben ja jetzt ein paar tausend Bundesligaspiele begleitet und aus den unterschiedlichsten Rollen heraus. Sie können sich ja wahrscheinlich auch noch daran erinnern, das erste Mal, wenn man in ein Stadion kommt, das erste Mal, wenn man so raustritt. Man verliert so ein bisschen im Job die Begeisterung dafür. Aber gibt es noch so Momente, wo sie das packt?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also das packt mich aber auch vor dem Bildschirm, wenn ich so ein Spiel wie gestern Abend sehe.
Also Inter gegen Barca, muss man dazu sagen.
Inter gegen Barca, ja. Aber auch letztes Jahr die Saison von Bayer Leverkusen. Oder auch mein anderer Herzensverein, der VfL Bochum, wenn er dann gut spielt, aber keine Punkte macht. Also da ist man immer schon noch dabei. Aber man hat natürlich letztendlich zwei Brillen auf. Und mir hat mal ein Vereinsvertreter gesagt, Herr Nehl, Sie haben es gut. Sie können immer in jedes Stadion gehen, wo Sie wollen. Und Ihnen ist egal, wer gewinnt oder verliert. Da hat er mal grundsätzlich recht. Aber dass ich jetzt im Stadion immer ohne Spannung und ohne Druck bin, weil es halt eben mitunter große Produktionen sind, wie so ein deutscher Klassikoo, der weltweit distribuiert wird, da kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich da nicht ohne Druck ins Stadion gehe, sondern auch froh bin, wenn es dann am Ende vorbei ist. Aber grundsätzlich hat er natürlich recht. Bei mir zählen nicht die Tore, sondern dass die Übertragung gut funktioniert hat.
Also Sie haben ja vor allem für Bochum und für Leverkusen gespielt. Sie haben es ja gerade schon angesprochen. Wie war denn dann Ihre Gefühlslage beim Spiel gegen Werder Bremen, als es dann auch relativ früh klar war, okay, jetzt klappt es mit der Meisterschaft, aber gleichzeitig sind ja die Fans in den Innenraum, die Banden sind kollabiert. Da macht man sich ja auch Sorgen um das eigene Übertragungsprodukt, oder?
Ja, aber da sind wir natürlich schon geübt. Also wenn wir wissen, an den letzten Spieltagen aus Freude oder Frust, dann bauen wir zehn Minuten vorher schon bestimmte Kamerapositionen ab, die also die flachen Kameras, die auf dem Platz sind oder wo eine Gefährdungslage besteht. Und dann machen wir das nicht mit 20 Kameras zu Ende, sondern eben mit 12. Das geht da nicht anders, weil der Schaden mitunter dann doch so groß ist, dass man dann auch mal fünf Minuten auf ein paar Kameras verzichten kann.
Und Richtmikrofone vermute ich auch.
Auch, ja. Es gibt so eine Liste an Equipment, die wir im Kopf haben, wo wir vorher wissen, das räumen wir mal besser ab, sonst finden wir es nicht mehr wieder.
Also das heißt, konnten Sie das dann total genießen als ehemaliger Leverkusener Spieler, diesen größten Erfolg?
Ja, definitiv. Ich hatte auch die Familie dazu eingeladen, weil es einfach etwas Besonderes ist. Und ich mich auch noch gut daran erinnern kann, wie wir mit Leverkusen mal Herbstmeister geworden sind und dann am Ende hinten raus die Saison nicht gut gespielt haben. Und natürlich auch die Vizemeisterschaften, die Leverkusen gemacht hat. Also da ist schon dann am Ende zu ein paar Clubs eine Verbindung. Aber da würde ich mal sagen, die habe ich nicht nur zu Clubs, wo ich gespielt habe, sondern weil halt eben bestimmte Menschen dort mittlerweile arbeiten. Und über die vielen Jahrzehnte kenne ich natürlich sehr, sehr viele Leute. Und insofern hat man dann doch auch Sympathien und freut sich mit den Clubs mit, wenn sie etwas Besonderes geleistet haben. Das ist dann die Begeisterung für den Sport und dass man sich für andere Menschen mitfreut. Und wenn es dann auch mal der eigene Club ist, so wie letztes Jahr Leverkusen, freut man sich natürlich umso mehr.
Ja gut, da hatten sie ja sowieso das Herzschlagfinale mit Bochum noch in der Relegation. Also war eine anstrengende Zeit der letzte Mai, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, das war schon sehr anstrengend. Aber wie gesagt, es gibt da zwei Seiten. Das eine ist die berufliche und das andere ist sozusagen die Freude über den Sport und alles, was damit zu tun hat.
Lassen Sie mal auf Ihre Zeit als Spieler blicken. Als Sie damals zum VfL Bochum gekommen sind, hat der damalige Präsident Otto K. Wüst gesagt, toll, jetzt haben wir endlich mal jemanden, der auch ein Buch liest und nicht immer nur Videos schaut am Nachmittag, weil sie eben nebenher schon studiert haben. Waren Sie denn wirklich so ein Sonderfall im Team?
Ja, ich glaube, dass man das auch im Kontext der Zeit sehen muss. Also heute wären Spieler, die auch studieren und sich für andere Dinge interessieren, ist heute anders. Es ist auch deutlich mehr geworden. Die Schule steht auch viel mehr im Vordergrund in den Nachwuchsleistungszentren. Der Mensch steht im Vordergrund, dass er sich entwickelt. Weil am Ende, es gibt nur ganz wenige Karrieren, die funktionieren. Und dann funktionieren sie auch nur zehn Jahre. Das heißt, man muss die Spieler dann anders vorbereiten. Das war früher alles komplett anders. Und mein Lebensweg war einfach so geprägt durchs Elternhaus, Schule, Studium. Und dann gucken wir mal, was es gibt. Ich war ja auch 24, als mein Vertrag unterschrieben habe beim VfL Bochum. Und insofern war es eine andere Zeit. Aber der gleiche Ottokavüste hat mir dann auch nach drei Monaten gesagt, nachdem ich dann auch mich sozusagen mal an alles gewöhnt hatte und dann im Herbst auch etwas müde wurde, weil dieses Pensum war ich natürlich nicht gewöhnt. Das war der gleiche Ottokavüste, der dann zu mir gesagt hat, Jupp, jetzt bleibst du mal schön im Bochum, legst dich nachmittags aufs Sofa und guckst dir mal ein Video an, um auszuholen. Also insofern, die Aussagen sind dann eine gewisse Kurzlebigkeit. Aber man muss dann irgendwie schauen, dass man dort allen dann gerecht wird. Das sind Zeiten im Vergleich zu heute, die komplett anders sind. Und ich, wenn ich, man hat ja nicht die Wahl, aber wenn ich die Wahl hätte, ich hätte viel lieber heute gespielt, weil es einfach dreimal professioneller ist, was die Trainingslehre angeht, was Physiorea angeht, was die Ernährung angeht, was taktische Themen angeht. Das ganze drum herum ist 0,0 vergleichbar mit den 90er oder 80er Jahren. Definitiv nicht. Und klar gibt es auch Sachen, die heute vielleicht nicht so schön sind, oder an die man sich dann auch mal gewöhnen müsste. Aber im Grunde genommen finde ich, dass das, was heute für die Spieler gemacht wird, auch mit der Fokussierung auf Schule, Ausbildung und so weiter, das ist schon große Klasse.
Also dazu muss man sagen, sie sind 86 zu Buchen gekommen und dann in der Saison 91 dann zu Leverkusen gewechselt. Das heißt, sie haben auch richtig diese, ich würde mal sagen, harte Phase im Bundesliga-Fußball miterlebt. Das Privatfernsehen kam schon rein und das hat einiges verändert an der Darstellung des Produkts und damit auch langsam an den Stadion besuchen. Aber wie war denn das damals für sie, Mitte der 80er in ja nicht wirklich gefüllten Stadien zu spielen, auch in nicht unbedingt immer sicheren Stadien zu spielen? Das war ja wirklich eine komplett andere Zeit zu heute.
Ja, also wie gesagt, man kann es 0,0 vergleichen. Es war das gleiche Spiel. Man hat es mit Kollegen zu tun. Man hat da Kollegen drunter. Mit denen kommt man sehr gut aus. Welche mit denen kommt man weniger gut aus. Der Kern war schon der gleiche, aber alles drum herum ist anders. Und insofern, das ist das, was ich meinte, dass in jeder Beziehung professionellere, das hätte ich deutlich lieber gehabt. Aber alles hat seine Zeit. Insofern hat es damals auch schöne Zeiten gehabt. Wir haben kein Social Media gehabt. Wir haben kein Bashing gehabt. Wir waren da schon noch ein bisschen freier als die Spieler heute. Aber man kann es am Ende auch nicht vergleichen.
Es sind fast zwei verschiedene Sportarten, zumindest wenn man sich Spiele von damals anguckt. Sie haben ja unter anderem 1988 ein Pokalfinale bestritten gegen Eintracht Frankfurt, die dann in der Folge Saison, weil sie 1-1 in Hannover gespielt haben, nur in die Relegation gekommen sind. Das war, glaube ich, nochmal eine ganz eigene Geschichte. Aber wir sind ja jetzt das Pokalfinale in Berlin gewohnt. Wir wissen auch, welches Highlight-Spiel das ist. Und jetzt gerade ganz besonders mit Arminia Bielefeld und VfB Stuttgart. Damals war das ja noch eine relativ junge Entscheidung, dass es in Berlin ausgetragen wird. Welche Erinnerungen haben Sie denn an dieses erste Pokalfinale?
Also es war natürlich schon was definitiv Besonderes. Die Stadt war geteilt in blau und schwarz-rot und überall, wo man hinging, wir waren in der Sportschule Grünwald, in den Grunewald und wir wollten einen Waldlauf machen. Und dann sagt der Herr Mergerland, jetzt gehen wir eine Runde raus und dann laufen wir eine Runde im Wald. Und es ging aber nicht mehr weiter, weil wir sind permanent gegen die Mauer gelaufen.
Also gegen die Mauer. Gegen die Mauer gelaufen.
Das war natürlich auch was Neues für uns. Aber die Fahrt ins Stadion, dann die ersten Schritte ins Stadion rein, also auf den Rasen, das war schon unfassbar. Die eine Seite blau, die andere schwarz-rot. Das war schon ein tolles, tolles Erlebnis. Dann haben wir leider verloren. Mit dem Videoschützrich hätten wir gewonnen, weil das Tor, das Epilife geschossen hatte, kein Absatz war. Und dann hat Laio Stetari einen tollen Freistoß über Torsten Leger ins Tor geschnippelt und dann haben wir 1-0 verloren. Aber es war trotzdem ein tolles Erlebnis, auch wenn man natürlich lieber als Sieger vom Platz geht.
Und wie wurde dann danach bei sowas gefeiert in Zeiten ohne Social Media?
Es gab dann am Ende ein gemeinsames Essen im Hotel. Und dann gab es ein paar Reden von unserem Ministerpräsidenten Rau damals auch noch.
Das klingt aber auch schon steif, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, das war auch steif. Vor allen Dingen seine Redete mündete mit den Worten, dabei sein ist alles. Aber das ist natürlich von Sportler, der gerade verloren hat. Alles andere als eine Aufmunderung. Und ja, das war aber auch das gleiche Prozedere war 93, als mit Leverkusen das Finale gewonnen haben auch. Gab danach ein Essen, eine Gala und danach irgendwann, bist du, wenn du noch konntest, auf die Straße ein bisschen feiern gegangen. Ja, es war eine andere Zeit. Also die Vokalfeier von Leverkusen in Berlin war jetzt was ganz anderes. Das war eine Party von vorne bis hinten und hatte nichts mit dem zu tun, so wie wir das früher in Anführungsstrichen gefeiert oder zelebriert haben.
Welches war denn das für sie jetzt im Nachhinein wichtigere Finale, das, wo sie nicht spielen konnten, aber den Titel geholt haben mit Leverkusen oder das, wo sie spielen konnten und es aber knapp verloren haben?
Ja, die beiden Endspiele miteinander zu vergleichen, ist auch schwierig. Wir haben ja gegen Hertha BSC Amateure mit Leverkusen gespielt. Jetzt bist du als Bayer Leverkusen normalerweise sowieso nicht der Sympathieträger. Und dann spielst du auch noch in Berlin gegen die Amateure von Hertha. Also undankbarer kann es fast nicht sein. Also insofern kann man die beiden Dinge nicht miteinander vergleichen. Ich habe beide Spiele gemacht bis zum Finale und war halt eben nur auf der Bank. Natürlich freust du dich dann über den Titel mehr als über einen zweiten Platz, egal gegen wen. Und ja, 88 zu spielen, das war schon eine besondere Erfahrung, wobei wir leider ein bisschen Pech hatten, weil mit Anji Ivan und Martin Kree zwei wichtige Spieler, die angeschlagen waren und bis zum Schluss nicht klar war, ob sie spielen konnten. Und es war so ein bisschen Verunsicherung in der Mannschaft. Da hätten wir mehr draus machen können, aber wie gesagt, vergossene Milch und alles tolle Erfahrungen. Und im Nachhinein nach 30 Jahren ist sowieso egal, ob der erste oder der zweite Tabüß.
Ja, naja. Ja, okay, das kann ich verstehen. Sagen Sie mir mal, welche Position haben Sie eigentlich gespielt? Denn ich habe selten jemanden gesehen, also natürlich eher offensiv, aber der so viele unterschiedliche Einsätze hatte und am Schluss ja sogar als Libero, da müssen wir dann gleich darüber sprechen. Da gibt es ein berühmtes Gladbach-Spiel. Aber sagen Sie mal jetzt so im Nachhinein, was würden Sie sagen, was war denn eigentlich Ihre hauptsächliche Position?
Also meine Lieblingsposition war natürlich immer der Mittelstürmer. Und nur wenn man natürlich auch älter wird, mehr Erfahrung sammelt, merkt man natürlich auch, dass andere Positionen auch reizvoll sind und dass man vielleicht auch noch andere Stärken hat. Und irgendwann ist es dir dann auch egal, weil am Ende entscheidet der Trainer, wo er dich hinstellt und du bist froh, dass du spielen darfst. Und ich habe auch alles wirklich, alles sehr gerne gespielt. Und anscheinend haben die Trainer dann auch ein gewisses Spielverständnis bei mir unterstellt, dass ich verschiedene Positionen spielen konnte. Das Einzige, was ich nicht gerne gemacht habe und da bin ich auch nicht für geboren, das war ein paar Spieler als Außenverteidiger. Also das ist nicht, das ist nicht mein Verständnis, Fußball zu spielen. Da bin ich viel zu weit vorne gedanklich, bin vielleicht auch, sagen wir mal, da nicht genug athletisch gewesen, um schneller kleiner Verteidiger zu sein. Aber ansonsten glaube ich, hätte man mich auch überall hinstellen können, bis auf Torwart. Wobei ich mein allererstes Spiel in der Jugend als Torwart gemacht habe. Wer auf die Idee gekommen ist, weiß ich auch nicht, aber war auch mein einziges Spiel. Und die Position sehe ich auch wirklich nicht.
Und wenn sie jetzt heute Fußball beobachten, schauen sie dann eher auf die Bewegung des Stürmers oder wie der Verteidiger versucht, ihn abzuwehren?
Nee, also ich schaue selten auf, also wenn ich natürlich einen Florian Wirt sehe, dann schaue ich natürlich auf den Spieler. Aber ansonsten schaust du mehr, wie schaffen die das eigentlich, sich rauszuspielen? Wie schaffen die das, gefährlich zu werden? Wie schaffen die das zu sichern? Spielen die gutes Vorchecking, schlechtes Vorchecking? Also eigentlich geht es mehr um den Gesamtblick. Was machen die eigentlich, um erfolgreich zu sein? Und das finde ich, das ist ja gerade das Spannende. Und wenn man noch mal so ein Spiel wie gestern abend im Zwischen Barcelona und Inter Maila hat, dass beide Mannschaften, die jeweils vor allem die Italiener, sechs Tore in zwei Spielen noch reinkriegen, also das zeigt eine Qualität, dass das, was die Barcelona da gemacht hat, dass das nicht immer zu verteidigen ist. Und das zeugt von der individuellen Klasse, aber auch von einer unfassbaren Mannschaftsleistung. Und insofern, das macht es dann aus, das macht Spaß. Und das will man dann auch verstehen, wie die das machen.
Ja, ich habe mir die Frage auch deshalb gestellt, weil sie ja eben schon so lange in unterschiedlichen Rollen Fußball verfolgen. Und ich hätte jetzt gesagt, fürs Produkt Bundesliga wäre der Offensivfußball immer besser. Und wir sind ja auch aktuell in einer Phase, in der viele Tore fallen in der Liga. Aber wir kommen auch aus einer Bewegung. Also ich sage mal so, Union Berlin ist jetzt nicht mit spektakulärem Offensivfußball in die Champions League gekommen. Haben Sie da auch so einen speziellen Blick drauf aus Sicht des Produkts?
Ja, aber da glaube ich auch, dass es auch ein bisschen wie eine Sinus Kurve ist. Also der sportliche Erfolg und auch die Qualität. Ich glaube, dass wir im Moment wieder in so einer Phase sind, wo die Sinus Kurve ein bisschen nach unten geht. Wenn innerhalb von drei Monaten zehn Trainer in der zweiten Liga getauscht werden, also lange sind wir hier auf die genauen Zahlen fest, aber das ist ja nun ein Zeichen dafür, dass irgendwas in den Clubs nicht stimmt, dass vielleicht falsche Prioritäten gesetzt worden sind oder falsche Kompetenzen da gerade gefragt sind. Natürlich ist auch für das Fernsehprodukt die Art und Weise und am Ende ist das Fußballspiel der Kern entscheidend, wie das Produkt ist, was wir produzieren. Aber das ist jetzt aus meiner Sicht Gott gegeben, wie die Clubs agieren, wie die Clubs sich aufstellen, was sie machen. Sicherlich die DFL, die kann da vielleicht in einer gewissen Weise ein bisschen drauf einwirken, aber letztendlich muss jeder Club selbst entscheiden, wie er welche Prioritäten und so weiter setzt, um erfolgreich zu sein oder wirtschaftlich zu gesunden oder wie auch immer. Ich glaube, das Thema Corona war natürlich ein mehr als heftiger Einschlag, wo niemand mit gerechnet hat und viele Unternehmen, auch in der freien Wirtschaft, sehr darunter gelitten haben. Aber das Thema Corona müsste jetzt auch mal durch sein. Und dann müssten wir uns mal wieder auf wesentliche Dinge beim Fußball konzentrieren. Ich glaube, dass die Clubs da auch mittlerweile professionell genug sind und gut genug aufgestellt sind, um dort wieder erfolgreiche Zeiten zu haben. Wie gesagt, es ist meistens eine Sinus-Kurve, was den sportlichen Erfolg angeht.
Aber was meinen Sie damit, den wesentlichen Dingen, auf die man sich jetzt mehr konzentrieren müsste?
Das steht mir nicht zu zu beurteilen, wie in den Clubs gearbeitet wird. Aber für mich ist nur ein klares Indiz, wenn so viele Trainer gewechselt werden, ist ja irgendwas schiefgelaufen. Also die Erwartungshaltung stimmt nicht mit dem überein, was am Ende in der Realität passiert. Also muss man sich da die Frage stellen, war unsere Erwartungshaltung zu hoch oder haben wir falsche Entscheidungen getroffen oder haben wir einfach nur Pech gehabt oder waren zu viele Spieler verletzt oder keine Ahnung, das ist ja in jedem Club anders. Und am Ende ist es so, sicherlich, wenn man sieht, der FC Bayern ist jetzt wieder Deutscher Meister geworden, haben sie diese Saison definitiv was anders und besser gemacht als in der letzten Saison. Das ist einfach ein Fakt. Aber was die jetzt im Einzelnen gemacht haben oder warum der VfL Bochum jetzt zwei Jahre, drei Jahre immer unten drin ist und vielleicht sie jetzt tatsächlich erwischt, das kann ich nicht beurteilen. Also insofern, ich kann nur was beschreiben. Und das ist das, was dann am Ende mehr oder weniger auch faktisch ist. Aber ich kann es nicht beurteilen, letztendlich oder begründen.
Und welchen Unterschied würde das jetzt für Sie in Ihrer Funktion jetzt als Geschäftsführer von Sportcast machen, wenn nicht der HSV und Köln aufsteigen in die erste Liga, sondern Elbersbach und Paderborn?
Ja, die Frage ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig zu beantworten. Natürlich sympathiere ich mit Köln und auch dem HSV. Auf deiner Seite finde ich es genauso wichtig zu akzeptieren, wenn Klubs wie Elbersberg oder auch Heidenheim, wenn die einfach gute Arbeit leisten. Da muss man einfach sagen, Respekt. Ihr habt nicht eine 50-jährige Bundesliga-Historie und ihr habt es trotzdem geschafft. Wir müssen uns nicht darüber unterhalten, dass eine Strahlkraft von dem 1. FC Köln größer ist als Elbersberg oder vom HSV als Heidenheim. Aber letztendlich für das Produkt wäre es natürlich besser. Aber es kann sich ja niemand aussuchen. Die Entscheidung findet auf dem Platz statt. Und wenn die Entscheidung so und so gefallen ist, dann fahren wir mit unserem Equipment in der Bundesliga nach Heidenheim und nicht zum HSV. Und als der HSV abgestiegen ist und wir dann die erste Saison produziert haben und der Produktionsverantwortliche, der für den HSV zuständig ist, mir sagte, er hätte sich nicht vorstellen können, dass man mit so einem kleinen Ü-Wagen und mit so wenig Kameras ein Spiel beim HSV produzieren. Also das ist schon ein großer Unterschied, ob sie mit 20 Kameras und einem großen Ü-Wagen anrollen.
Also erste Liga?
Genau, oder ob sie halt eben in der zweiten Liga, was immer noch vom Standard ein gutes Format ist mit sieben Kameras plus Torkameras und weiter, weiß ich was, das ist schon noch ein gutes Format, aber es sieht halt eben definitiv anders aus.
Und wie ist das, also das Sportliche, das ist ja, das entwickelt sich einfach so. Sie haben es ja gesagt, manche Teams schaffen es eben dann aufzusteigen und warum sollten sie das nicht verdient haben? Aber als Sie als der Herr der Bilder, sage ich jetzt mal, für Sie sind ja Infrastruktur und solche Dinge auch wichtig. Also wie viel anspruchsvoller ist es denn zum Beispiel in Heidenheim, dann Kamerapositionen zu finden, einen ähnlichen Standard zu produzieren, wie man ihn in einer großen Arena wie beim HSV hat?
Also das ist, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, es wäre trivial, stimmt natürlich nicht, weil die Stahlien ja auch kleiner sind. Aber wir haben hier bei uns auch eine Abteilung, die sich nur mit dem Thema Infrastruktur und den Clubs beschäftigt. Und dann gibt es eine Lizenzierungsordnung, da müssen bestimmte Dinge erfüllt werden. Und wenn wir dann halt eben feststellen, Heidenheim steigt auf und wir brauchen 20 Kamerapositionen, dann wird eben dahin gefahren und da wird geguckt und gemacht und getan, damit wir die 20 Kamerapositionen haben.
Schafft man die 20 dann auch? Weil Heidenheim hat ja eine Ausnahme bei manchen Lizenzierungsaufgaben, was Stahlien angeht.
Das funktioniert dann schon. Da greift auch dann die DFL und das Lizenzierungsverfahren ein. Das ist aber dann ein Zusammenspiel von uns mit den Clubs, mit der DFL und so weiter und so fort. Und am Ende sage ich immer, wenn und wenn es dann am Ende nicht funktioniert, dann bauen wir halt eben eine Kamera auf dem Übergangsstellplatz auf. Also wenn wir das in der Gesamtheit nicht schaffen, die Kamerapositionen alle zu finden, ja dann ist es halt eben so. Da müssen aber auch alle sagen, okay, es geht nie anders. Und das kann ja nicht bei uns liegen. Deswegen sage ich, wenn wir die Positionen nicht alle finden, dann bauen wir auch einen Übergangsstellplatz ein auf.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich ja gar nicht schon zu Sportcast wechseln. Wenn wir nochmal kurz zurückgehen in Ihre Karriere. Sie haben ja auch Relegation gespielt, unter anderem gegen Saarbrücken, gegen Anthony Yeboah. Hinspiel 1-0 gewonnen, Rückspiel Yeboah, schießt das 1 zu 0. In Bochum, da wurde es mal kurz ein bisschen zittriger, aber Sie haben die Relegation überstanden. Wie haben Sie denn damals als Spieler diese Zuspitzung der Saison empfunden? Also, dass man da eben in diese zwei Extraspiele noch mal rein durfte als Erstligist und die Zweitligist mussten rein?
Ja, also das Thema Relegation ist ein Thema, was man als Bundesligist definitiv hasst und nicht braucht. Klar, Sie haben recht. Ansonsten wären wir als Drittletzte direkt abgestiegen. Also insofern ist es dann doch was Gutes. Aber die Belastung ist schon erheblich. Also für einen Bundesligaklub und da meine ich jetzt nicht nur die Mannschaft, sondern der ganze Betrieb, die Geschäftsstelle und so weiter und so fort bis hin zur ganzen Stadt. Also wir waren, die Freude in Berlin war größer, aber die Erleichterung war in Bochen größer, als wir die Relegation geschafft haben. Also das muss man einfach sagen. Und ich war ja zu der Zeit zwei, drei Jahre Profi und habe mich ja in der Zeit auch immer noch als Student gesehen. Das heißt, ich habe immer noch einen Plan B gehabt. Ja, und das an der Stelle dann vielleicht auch ganz wichtig. Dass man immer einen Plan B hat.
Aber hätten sie den bei einem Abstieg auch gebraucht? Saß so?
Nein, aber der Punkt ist ja, man hat ja nicht mehr alles in der Hand. Und mein Thema war ganz klar, ich mache mein Studium zu Ende und werde irgendwann mal als Diplomkaufmann irgendwo arbeiten. Also nur sofern war ich an der Stelle komplett beruhigt, dass mich das nicht persönlich, also es würde mich persönlich treffen, aber nicht so, dass es für mich so elementar gewesen wäre. Und insofern war ich da schon in einer besonderen Situation, aber die Anstrengung selbst und das ganze Drumherum, das war schon sehr, sehr, sehr anstrengend.
Und was waren dann ihre Gedanken, als die Relegation wieder eingeführt wurde?
Ja, so wie ich es eben gesagt habe. Ansonsten steigt man als Dritter der Bundesliga ab. Und ich sag mal, also das, was im letzten Jahr mit sich in Bochum und Düsseldorf gewesen ist, ja, also das kann ja nicht mehr brutaler sein auf beiden Seiten wie die beiden Spiele. Ein Spektakel, im Zweifel für beide Beteiligten, aber für die Spieler im Zweifel alles andere als ein Spektakel. Weil das müssen wir erstmal verkraften. Normalerweise ist es so, wenn wir mit dem VfL Bochum keine gute Saison gespielt haben und gerade so vom Abstieg weggekommen sind, haben wir danach in der Regel eine gute Saison gespielt. Das hätte ich jetzt beim VfL Bochum auch erwartet, aber ich glaube auch, weil wir auch eine andere Zeit haben, sind einige Spieler weggegangen, die doch deutlich Substanz, einen deutschen Substanzverlust bedeutet haben. Und dann haben sie vielleicht auch ein bisschen Pech gehabt diese Saison, aber eine bessere Saison als letzte Saison haben sie auch nicht gespielt.
Ja, es ist eben alles sehr, sehr eng geworden. Aber wenn man sich die Saisonverläufe in den 80er anguckt, war es ehrlicherweise damals auch so. Also es wurde immer am 34. Spieltag noch mal eine Entscheidung getroffen und einmal spielt Eintracht Frankfurt nur 1 zu 1 bei Hannover, einmal verliert St. Pauli 2-5 gegen BVB und so weiter und so fort. Sie haben jetzt gerade auch schon wieder ihr Studium angesprochen. Das haben sie ja dann beendet, sind dann zum Teil aus dem Trainingslager zur Examsprüfung gefahren und wieder zurück. Und ich habe unterschiedliche Dinge gelesen über ihren Wechsel dann von Bochum zu Leverkusen. Auf der einen Seite habe ich gelesen, unter anderem soll das ein Problem gewesen sein, nämlich die Belastung der Examsprüfung. Und ich habe aber auch gelesen, dass sie mit Holger Osiek, dem neuen Trainer, nicht so zurecht kam und ich sehe sie nicken, das war's.
Holger Osiek kam zum VfL Bochum und hat den Eindruck vom Mittel, jetzt rocken wir hier mal die Liga. Und der Punkt ist, wenn man viele Tore schießt, kann man vielleicht auch ein paar Spiele gewinnen, aber wenn man zu viele Tore reinkriegt, wirst du die Saison verlieren. Also wir waren, keine Ahnung, wir waren nicht auf einer Wellendänge. Und ja, alles weitere. Da gab es dann auch ein paar unschöne Geschichten und so weiter. Aber alles, nein, alles, alles kalter Kaffee. Und insofern war der Anruf von Reinhard Saftig und Bayer Leverkusen für beide Seiten einfach Gold wert. Ja, weil so konnten wir gut auseinandergehen. Der VfL hat eine vergleichsweise ordentliche Ablösesumme für die damaligen Zeiten bekommen. Und ich war ehrlicherweise ja auch ein bisschen stolz, wechseln zu können. Bei Leverkusen schon ganz andere Ansprüche hatte als der VfL Bochum. Ja, also ohne da jetzt eine Wertung reinzubringen. Ich habe mich beim VfL Bochum die ganze Zeit vorher wirklich sehr, sehr wohl gefühlt und habe auch sehr von den Alten profitiert, wie Lamek, Völk und Oswald und so weiter und so fort. Und es hat super viel Spaß gemacht. Aber dann kam irgendwo der Punkt und als Spieler kommen sie auch nicht gegen den Trainer an. Also da müssen sie einfach wissen, dass das nicht geht.
Damals glaube ich noch weniger als heute. Sie haben über 140 Spiele für den VfL gemacht. Von welchen Mitspielern ist der Abschied am schwersten gefallen?
Eigentlich waren da ganz viele gute Jungs. Aber ich habe die meiste Zeit meist immer mit Rob Rekers geteilt. Und der Rob kam auch genau im gleichen Jahr wie ich zum VfL. Wir waren also sozusagen der gleiche Jahrgang, auch wenn er viel jünger ist beim VfL. Und ja, das war so mein Buddy die ganze Zeit.
Also ich kann nur allen Hörerinnen und Hörern empfehlen, schaut euch noch mal ein paar Startaustellungen von damals an. Da sind wirklich einige Namen mit dabei. Da klingen einem die Ohren, selbst wenn man das damals nicht aktiv miterlebt hat. Sie haben schon wirklich mit Bundesliga-Größen zusammengespielt. Und so ging es ja bei Leverkusen auch weiter. Und gleichzeitig haben sie bei Leverkusen eben in einer ganz interessanten Phase gespielt. Und zwar sowohl sportlich, das haben sie ja gerade schon angedeutet. Und das drückt sich ja unter anderem im DFB-Pokal-Titel aus. Aber ja auch von der Art und Weise, wie sich der Blick auf die Bundesliga verändert hat. Wir haben die Wendezeit, der Stadionbesuch verändert sich. Sie haben eben einmal im Pokalfinale im geteilten Berlin gespielt. Und dann haben sie eins im wiedervereinten Berlin gespielt. Welche Erinnerungen haben sie denn an diese Zeit bei Leverkusen?
Also, sie haben es genau richtig beschrieben. Das war so die Nachwendezeit, wenn man das so sagen darf. Wir hatten Ulf Kirsten, Antitom, er überragende Fußballer. Wir hatten aber auch Pavel Hapal und Ion Dupescu. Wir hatten wirklich eine Weltmannschaft. Wirklich. Also, ich nehme mich jetzt mal raus, aber da waren schon ein paar dabei, die richtig, richtig gut waren. Dann kam Berns Schuster und Rudi Völler noch dazu. Paulo Sergio, allen voran Jorginho, unser Kapitän, Weltmeisterkapitän der brasilianischen Nationalmannschaft 94. Das war schon grandios und ehrlicherweise, dass wir da nicht einmal durchgelaufen sind bis zur Meisterschaft, ist wirklich im Nachhinein für mich der Hammer, dass wir das nicht geschafft haben mit der Truppe. Aber was man natürlich auch sagen muss, das war natürlich auch eine Zeit, da wir hatten viele Spiele, die aus der früheren DDR kamen, das war so eine kleine Gruppe, dann ein bisschen die Brasilianer, dann die Älteren. Und ich glaube, dass das nicht kein Trainer so richtig geschafft hat, da so eine eingeschworene Mannschaft daraus zu machen. Von den Einzelspielern her war das unfassbar. Also wenn sie mit Rudi Völler und mit Bernd Schutze auf dem Platz stehen und Paulo Sergio und Giorginio, da geht nicht mehr viel mehr. Und das war schon eine tolle Zeit, war auch anstrengend, weil auch immer irgendwas war. Und dann war mal was im Spiele, mal was im Training und so weiter und so fort.
Also ein Auseinandersetzungen.
Ja, genau, weil es einfach so ein bisschen grübschen Bildung gab, auch was ich von VfL her nicht kannte. Aber da gab es auch den berühmten Spruch von Atalamec, der gesagt hat, Jupp, in der Bundesliga steigt nie die schlechteste Mannschaft ab, sondern die Mannschaft, die keine Mannschaft ist. Und das Gleiche gilt nicht nur für einen Nichtabstieg, sondern auch für eine Meisterschaft oder sonst diese Großen, wo sie die ganze Saison zusammenstehen müssen. Das war jetzt nicht so, als wenn jeder dem anderen sein Teufel war. Aber so der letzte Aspekt des Zusammenmalts, der hätte besser sein können. Das hätte besser sein können. Und auf der anderen Seite war die Zeit in Leverkusen natürlich auch etwas freier, weil beim Vorfeldbochum hieß immer, wie viele Zuschauer sind gekommen. Können wir die Gelder bezahlen und, und, und. Die Zeiten änderten sich. Es gab mehr Fernsehgeld. Die Fragen nach Gehältern oder dass der Rainer Kallmund mal an einem Sonntag zu einer Krisensitzung antreten musste und uns mal die Köpfe gewaschen hat, weil Gefahr in Verzug war. Das hat es in Leverkusen nicht gegeben.
Aber das war ja damals eine sehr, sehr wilde Zeit. Und gerade Rainer Kallmund war sehr gut darin, gute ostdeutsche Spieler zu Leverkusen zu holen. Und ja, so gut darin, dass er das sogar gebremst werden musste. Die berühmte Helmut Kohl Anekdote, Matthias Sammer und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, das wäre vielleicht im Zweifel der entscheidende Spieler gewesen, der Matthias Sammer.
Also Helmut Kohl ist schuld?
Nein, nein, nein. Also, ich glaube nicht. Natürlich ist ja auch die Frage, wie viele Spieler holst du dann rüber und wie setzt du es zusammen und so weiter. Der Ansatz hätte ja auch ein anderer sein können, wobei ich auch bei vielen guten Fußballspielern, Andreas Thun war einer auch der ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz überragenden Fußballer. Ja, also insofern, aber Matthias Sammer wäre vielleicht der Mentalitätsspieler gewesen im Sinne der Gruppe, den wir vielleicht gebraucht hätten.
Jetzt wissen wir ja im Nachhinein, dass diese Phase für den ostdeutschen Fußball ein regelrechtes Ausbluten war und dass so wenige ostdeutsche Vereine sich bis in die höchste Spielklasse durchgesetzt haben, liegt sicherlich auch an Fehlern, die damals gemacht wurden. Wie blicken Sie denn jetzt mit dem Wissen von heute auf diese Zeit zurück?
Also die neuen Bundesländer haben eigentlich in der Bundesliga gar nicht stattgefunden. Also ich glaube, ich habe ein Spiel in Dresden mal gemacht, ein Spiel in Rostock mal gemacht.
Das war dann 91-92 die Saison.
Genau. Und der Osten ist ausgeblutet. Und insofern muss ich schon sagen, also Leipzig als Fußballstandort, das muss man sagen, ist schlau überlegt worden, von Red Bull dorthin zu gehen und das Projekt dort zu starten. Und bis heute erfolgreich zu starten. Wenn jetzt in Leipzig gar nichts wäre, kein Bundesligastandort wäre, das wäre schon für die gesamten Bundesländer sehr wenig.
Aber glauben Sie, dass Leipzig der Standort ist, hinter dem sich die ostdeutschen Fußballfans vereinigen können? Bei dem Eindruck habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Die kriegen ja nicht mehr ihr Stadion voll.
Ich kann das nicht beurteilen, weil ich zu weit davon entfernt lebe. Und das, was wir dort machen, das ist einfach, wenn man mit mit mit RB arbeitet, ist einfach professionell. Egal in welcher Hinsicht. Und insofern bin ich auch jemand, der sich eher darüber freut, dass es Clubs gibt wie Leipzig, wie Hoffenheim, wie Wolfsburg. Klar, ich komme aus Leverkusen. Ich habe da natürlich dann am Ende ein bisschen einen anderen Blick da drauf. Nur auf der anderen Seite, wie viele Clubs haben wir denn, die gesund und einigermaßen erfolgreich sind, die mal den Bayern einigermaßen das Wasser reichen können?
Aber das können ja Wolfsburg und Hoffenheim auch nicht und Leipzig ja auch nicht eigentlich.
Also ja, natürlich sind es andere Konzepte, definitiv. Aber ich erinnere mich in der ersten Zeit von Hoffenheim, das war ja der Stern. Und Leipzig hat es auch geschafft, vorzudringen bis in die Champions League und so weiter und so fort. Ich finde, dass das unsere Landschaft reicher gemacht hat. Und wenn wir jetzt auf die Clubs Schalke, Köln, HSV warten, damit die wieder ein großes, was machen wir in der Zwischenzeit, dann spielen wir dann mit 13 Clubs oder 14 Clubs. Ja, jeder muss seinen Platz verteidigen und die haben es geschafft, mit Konzepten und Kompetenz da oben rein zu laufen.
Und mit viel Geld natürlich, muss man auch sagen. Also gerade Wolfsburg ist eine Geldverbrennungsmaschine.
Ja, aber da muss ich ehrlich sagen, da wäre ich vorsichtig. Ich will jetzt auch nicht die Clubs untereinander vergleichen, weil mir das nicht zusteht. Aber das ist jetzt nicht so, dass überall einfach die Dollars vom Himmel fallen, sondern das Geld muss auch irgendwo herkommen und erarbeitet werden. Und es sind keine russischen Dollar und keine arabischen Dollar oder sonstigen Dollars. Also insofern bin ich da ein bisschen zurückhaltender in der Beurteilung. Ich glaube, so Clubs wie Schalke, HSV, Köln, die 50, 60 Jahre Vorsprung gehabt haben, was aufzubauen und zu entwickeln und das dann gegenüber zu sagen Red Bull oder Hoffenheim, das ist nicht in Ordnung. Da muss man vorsichtig in der Beurteilung sein.
Das ist ja völlig klar und die Kritik an solchen Vereinen bedeutet ja nicht, dass man ihnen automatisch, manche tun das natürlich, aber man muss sie nicht automatisch missgönnen, wo sie jetzt gerade stehen oder das kleinreden. Aber ich würde jetzt sagen, sie als jemand, der eben das Produkt Bundesliga ja letztlich auch herstellt, für sie macht es doch schon einen Unterschied, ob Hoffenheim gegen Wolfsburg spielt oder der HSV gegen Köln.
Definitiv. Und die zweite Liga hat sich ja jetzt über ein paar Jahre auch darüber gefreut und an Attraktivität vielleicht gewonnen.
Aber stellen Sie sich das nicht manchmal jetzt mit der ersten Liga vor, dass Sie sich denken, meine Güte, wenn jetzt der HSV und Köln gerade um die Champions League spielen würden und meinetwegen in der zweiten Liga Hoffenheim und Wolfsburg um den Aufstieg, was da möglich wäre mit dem Produkt Bundesliga auch international vielleicht?
Ja, das ist jetzt eine weite Tür, die Sie jetzt aufmachen international. Am Ende, ich halte mich an das, was in der Tabelle steht.
Klar.
Ja, natürlich würde ich mir vielleicht...
Aber du würdest Ihren Job nicht einfacher machen. Weil wir haben ja durchaus wirklich viele Bilder von halbleeren Stadien inzwischen. Und mein Eindruck ist schon, dass versucht wird, durch gewisse Schnitte die Führungskamera dann nicht immer zeigen zu müssen, damit man das auch nicht immer so erkennt. Weil es sieht ja einfach nicht gut aus.
Also das ist definitiv nicht... In unserem Regieleitfaden steht nicht drin, wir zeigen keine leeren Tribünen. Also in unserem Regieleitfaden steht als erstes drin, das Wichtigste ist das Spiel. Wenn der Ball rollt, sind wir da, wo der Ball rollt. So und das zweite ist, dass wir das zeigen, was im Stadion passiert. Und ich sag jetzt mal, wenn ein Flitzer darüber läuft, dann zeigen wir den nicht im Vollbild, aber wir zeigen im Stadion, dem Zuschauer, was da passiert. Wenn geraune ist, dann zeigen wir, warum das geraune ist.
Was ist mit Transparenten zum Beispiel von Ultras? Sieht man eigentlich nie?
Wir sind nicht diejenigen, die für Aussagen zuständig sind. Wir sind verantwortlich für das Spiel, für das, was da passiert. Und das ist am Ende auch dann der Lizenznehmer, der eigene Kamera es ja noch hat, ob ihr bestimmte Themen aufgreift oder nicht aufgreift.
Das heißt, es gibt eigentlich immer auch die Perspektive auf, hier wird gerade dieses Transparent gezeigt. Und die Lizenznehmer von Sky the Zone entscheiden, ob sie es zeigen.
Genau, jeder Lizenznehmer hat das Recht und die Möglichkeit, eigene Kameras im Stadion zu positionieren. Und wenn die das zum Thema machen, dann machen die das zum Thema.
Aber eine Sportcast-Kamera filmt jetzt nicht, eine von den 20. Weil man weiß ja nicht, welche Rolle das vielleicht auch mal später spielen könnte. Natürlich, ich verstehe, dass man jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit unterbrechen kann, das Spiel umzuzeigen. Hier, gucken Sie mal, da ist eine neue Tapete hochgegangen. Aber das sind ja für manche Fans wichtige Themen und die könnten ja auch noch eine größere Bedeutung bekommen. Und da muss man gar nicht in die Extremen gehen, wie eben irgendwelche Dietmar Hopp-Fadenkreuz-Transparente.
Ja, also ich sag mal, solche Dinge verbieten sich, glaube ich, schon von alleine. Und die müssen wir jetzt nicht transportieren.
Na, die wurden aber ja transplantiert. Das ist ja das Interessante. Also ich will Ihnen das jetzt nicht zuvor rufen. Das ist ja auch nicht Ihre Entscheidung. Aber verstehen Sie meine Argumentation, dass wenn Sie sagen, wir wollen, natürlich steht das Spiel immer im Zentrum, aber es gibt Teile im Stadion, da habe ich eben nicht den Eindruck, dass ich im Fernsehen gerade verstehe, was passiert. Also wenn Pyrotechnik gezündet wird, sehe ich das manchmal so in einem Anschnitt, aber auch nicht immer. Manchmal sieht man Rauchtöpfe erst dann, wenn sie auch das Spielfeld zeigen.
Aber wenn sie zukünftig mal darauf achten, dann werden wir immer nur dann etwas anderes zeigen, wenn der Ball nicht rollt.
Ja, das ist mir schon aufgefallen.
So. Und dann gibt es eine klare Ansage, dass wir alles zeigen, was im Stadion passiert. Und wenn da ein Plakat oder Pyrotechnik, wir gehen nicht groß drauf, aber wir zeigen es aus der Totalen. Das ist unsere Vorgehensweise. Wir sind nicht die, die am Ende dafür zuständig sind, eine Meinung zu machen oder Dinge zu forcieren. Dafür gibt es genug Lizenznehmer, die die Themen aufnehmen können. Wir sind erst mal dafür da, das Spiel so abzubilden, wie es im Stadion vor Ort stattfindet.
Gut. Und dazu muss man ja auch sagen, Sie produzieren ja das Signal für alle. Und ich schaue auch viele Spiele im Worldfeed über meinen Y-Scout-Account. Und logischerweise, die Kommentatoren da, die wissen jetzt gar nicht immer, worum geht es jetzt bei dieser Tapete und können das gar nicht mehr erklären. Also das ist natürlich auch...
Ja, am Ende ist ja so, vom ersten Tag an, als Sportcast gegründet wurde und angefangen hat, dann hieß es immer direkt, ihr zeigt ja nur das, was ihr wollt und was für den Fußball gut ist. Und meine Antwort war immer Nein. Ja, und im Gegensatz zu UEFA und FIFA zeigen wir alles. Das heißt, unser Anspruch ist es nicht, Dinge nicht zu zeigen. Aber wenn Dinge nicht gezeigt werden, aus welchem Grund auch immer, hat jeder Lizenznehmer die Möglichkeit, seine eigene Kamera zu positionieren. Und Dinge, die wir nicht zeigen, aus welchem Grund auch immer, er kann sie zeigen.
Wenn er dran gedacht hat, die Kamera mitzubringen.
Ja gut, es gibt schon gewisse redaktionelle Konzepte, die das vorsehen. Und dann kann jeder Lizenznehmer reagieren.
Ich sehe schon, ich freue mich auf den ganzen Sportcast-Teil, aber ich möchte trotzdem noch, ich muss mit Ihnen über Ihre Zeit als Libero sprechen. Sie haben ein paar Spiele als Libero gemacht. Und unter anderem eins bei Borussia Mönchengladbach. Da haben Sie schon nach acht Minuten die rote Karte für eine Notbremse gesehen. Leverkusen hat dieses Spiel trotzdem gewonnen mit 3 zu 2. Wie kam es denn dazu, dass Sie noch Libero gespielt haben? Und jetzt nach dem, was Sie vorhin nämlich über Ihre Spielposition gesagt haben, kann ich mir vorstellen, Sie hatten auf jeden Fall das Spielverständnis dafür. Aber vielleicht, also ich glaube weiter vorne hätte es Ihnen schon auch getaugt.
Ja, können Sie mir noch sagen, welche Saison das war?
Das müsste 1992, 1993 gewesen sein. Nein, Entschuldigung 1995. Entschuldigung, ich bin hier gerade verrutscht. Da war das also schon die Endphase Ihrer Karriere.
Da war ich eigentlich schon, glaube ich, draußen. Und dann. Ich habe noch ein Jahr bei den Amateuren gespielt in Leverkusen und da da muss dieses Spiel gewesen sein. Ich weiß nicht, wer da Trainer war, ob Peter Hermann. Man kriegt sich einen Anruf in meinem Büro, ob ich nicht am Freitag mich nochmal zur Verfügung stehen könnte. Ich würde ja in Amateuren spielen, also werden so Spiele Spieler verletzt. Und dann habe ich dieses Spiel gemacht. Aber ich sage jetzt mal, das war eine Fehlentscheidung. Die rote Karte, Klammer auf, Klammer zu. Vielleicht war ich auch zu langsam.
Gibt es Bilder davon? Sie haben ja die große Datenbank mit aufgebaut hier. Haben Sie sich das nochmal angeguckt?
Nee.
Lieber nicht draufgucken. Nee? Nein, ich habe keine Bilder gefunden. Ich habe ja keinen Zugriffleiter auf diese Sachen.
Ach so, okay. Nee, das mache ich grundsätzlich nicht. Ich arbeite hier als Geschäftsführer und nicht als jemand, der permanent im Archiv seine Bilder sucht.
Ich wüsste nicht, ob ich das schaffen würde, ob ich nicht manchmal so ein halbes Überstündchen machen würde und mich da ein bisschen durchklicken würde.
Das ist, glaube ich, ich will es gar nicht, um nicht in die Versuchung zu kommen, nicht mehr aufhören zu können.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Und deswegen, lass mal das mal schön, lass mal das mal lieber sein.
Aber wie ist denn da der Stand bei dieser Datenbank, die aufgebaut wurde, und wo eben auch die Spielszenen verteckt sein sollen? Da gab es ja schon vor vielen Jahren schon Berichte, dass man da dran sitzt. Sind Sie damit fertig?
Ja, das ist natürlich ein laufender Prozess. Und dieses Digital Archiv, was heute Media Hub heißt, was sich durch Media Library hieß, das ist natürlich sozusagen auch schon mittlerweile zentrale Hub unserer Produktion, gerade fürs internationale Produktportfolio. Da finden Sie schon unfassbar viel. Also 100.000 von Stunden, die auch teilweise verschlagwortet sind. Also wenn es Material gibt und es gibt ein paar Jahre, das muss um die RTL-Zeit gewesen sein, da haben wir nicht alles komplett. Das hat Gründe der Lizenznehmer, Ufer, Bertelsmann, RTL. Aber ansonsten finden Sie schon sehr, sehr viel und auch sehr viel verschlagwortet. Das ist wirklich von alten Beiträgen aus dem aktuellen Sportstudio bis hin zu Live-Spielen in UAD.
Und jetzt muss man ja dazu sagen, Sportcast produziert auch zum Teil ganze Shows, die eben an die Lizenznehmer zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Das sind meistens so drei verschiedene Formate. Und dann, wenn ich eben das Recht kaufe, international natürlich, wenn ich mir das Recht erwerbe, Bundesliga zu zeigen, dann kann ich mir auch so ein fertiges Produkt kaufen, wenn ich möchte. Warum machen Sie so einen Zugang wie zum Media Hub? Warum öffnen Sie den nicht noch weiter? Ist es wichtig, dass da wirklich nur die Lizenznehmer, die viele, viele Millionen dafür zahlen, darauf Zugriff haben? Weil da liegen ja unglaubliche Schätze, die eigentlich gehoben werden könnten und gut für die Bundesliga aussehen.
Ja, die Bundesliga hat aber als Kunde heute die verschiedenen Lizenznehmer und nicht den Direktkonsumenten und man müsste sich jetzt überlegen, ob man in der Zukunft das Geschäftsmodell der Bundesliga verändert und dann wäre das sicherlich auch ein Punkt, wo man direkt Zugriffe auf dieses Archiv gestatten könnte. Das ist aber eine Frage, die uns ja in der jetzt heutigen Zeit sehr beschäftigt. Wie sieht das zukünftige Geschäftsmodell der DFL aus? Wie sieht das Geschäftsmodell der Bundesliga aus? Wird die DFL auf Dauer ihre Rechte an die Lizenznehmer verkaufen, und die das Produkt dann für ihre Plattformen, Sender oder auf ihren Sendern vermarkten, verwerten? Oder wird die Liga selbst auch irgendwann mal direkt Kundenkontakt aufnehmen?
Also mit einem eigenen Streaming-Angebot zum Beispiel?
Ja.
Haben sie da geschwitzt, als es um den Investoreneinstieg von CWC ging?
Ja, man hat ein bisschen gemischte Gefühle. Man weiß natürlich, dass ich in Zukunft auch was ändern muss. Aber der Weg dahin ist natürlich dann doch kompliziert und mit viel Diskussion verbunden. Und am Ende hat ja die ganze Diskussion, der ganze Prozess gesehen, dass es keine einheitliche Meinung in der Liga gab. Und dann ist der Prozess ja auch abgebrochen mit dem Hinweis, dass wenn wir nicht eine relevante Gruppe haben, die dahinterstehen, dann macht es am Ende keinen Sinn. Und das, glaube ich, das, was jetzt diskutiert werden muss, damit man eine mehr als fähige Konzeption oder Strategie entwickelt. Ich kann Ihnen gar nicht sagen, ob ich mich darüber gefreut habe oder nicht gefreut habe. Die Diskussion war so weit weg, weil für mich ist natürlich auch erstmal entscheidend, was passiert hier. Und ein Signal muss so oder so produziert werden. Und wie das Signal hinten heraus verkauft, verwertet oder vermarktet wird, ist dann eine ganz andere Diskussion. Und das wäre die Diskussion gewesen. Die ist von uns relativ weit weg.
Das heißt, es hat auch keine Rolle gespielt. Weil mir ist aufgefallen, dass während der ersten Diskussion um den Investoreneinstieg wurde Ihr Vertrag bei Sportcast verlängert. Und das hat damit überhaupt gar nichts zu tun gehabt.
Null, null.
Und wie würden Sie es sich wünschen, dass sich die Bundesliga weiterentwickelt? Wären Sie für eine eigene Plattform?
Ja, aber das sind Diskussionen, die wir intern führen, wie der möglicherweise richtige Weg für die Zukunft sein wird. Ob es noch mal eine Ausschreibung gibt in vier Jahren, so wie sie jetzt gewesen ist, oder ob man was anderes versucht oder einen anderen Weg geht, aber gleichzeitig die Lizenznehmer mit einbindet. Da gibt es ja ganz viele Möglichkeiten, die müssen jetzt diskutiert werden. Aber jetzt ist erst mal Start der neuen Rechteperiode im Juli, August. Und wir haben eine veränderte Konstellation am Samstag. Und darauf stellen wir uns jetzt mal ein und unterstützen die Lizenznehmer in dem, was sie gekauft haben, was sie vermarkten müssen, wollen, damit wir da wieder ein gutes Produkt haben und sozusagen die Lizenznehmer auch zufrieden sind. Und dann, wenn alles mal läuft, nach den ersten Monaten, dann kann man allmählich anfangen, sich Gedanken zu machen. Und das ist einfach auch ein normaler Prozess, der auch schon etliche Male auch schon unter Christian Seifert durchgeführt wurde. Dass man sich Gedanken macht, was passiert denn am Ende der Lizenzperiode, weil die Zeit ja doch dann irgendwann ras und die Lizenznehmer und Partner auch einen gewissen Vorlauf brauchen mit dem, was sie selbst erwartet. Das muss man dann diskutieren. Dann hat man eine gewisse Zeit jetzt, in den nächsten anderthalb Jahren, sich genau zu überlegen und zu prüfen, zu analysieren, wie geht man jetzt den nächsten Schritten und was ist der nächste Weg.
Hat es Sie überrascht, dass Sky jetzt erst jüngst angekündigt hat, eine Multiview-Option anzubieten, also verkürzt gesagt, man kann sich aus den Einzelspielen, die ja noch bei Sky liegen, eine Konferenz bauen mit kleineren Einschränkungen?
Also kurze Antwort, nein, mich überrascht nichts. Es muss nur alles konform sein zu den Ausschreibungsregularien, die die DFL mit allen Lizenznehmern vereinbart hat.
Und das ist es demnach?
Da kann ich leider jetzt im Moment nichts zu sagen, weil ich nicht jedes Detail der Ausschreibung kenne.
Will man, glaube ich, auch nicht kennen, nachdem wie die Ausschreibung lief. Das interessiert, glaube ich, vor allem Juristen. Schauen Sie denn dann gerade auch mit besonderem Interesse auf die Ligue 1 und was da passiert ist zwischen der Zone und der Liga. Jetzt scheint man sich ja zu einigen, der Zone kommt aus dem Vertrag billiger raus, sage ich jetzt mal so platt und hilft aber gleichzeitig beim Aufbau eben einer eigenen Streaming-Plattform.
Ja, also ich finde, das ist auch ein Teil unserer Entwicklung und Geschichte, dass wir uns auch anschauen, was in anderen Ländern oder in anderen Sportarten passiert. Und das, was jetzt in Frankreich passiert, ist natürlich mehr als spannend. Auch die Entwicklung in Spanien ist entspannt und entscheidend. Man sieht auch andere Sportarten. Man sieht beispielsweise auch, was für ein großes Produktionszentrum die PGA gebaut hat, die ja auch selbst produziert und jetzt sozusagen auch mehr und mehr sich zur eigenen eigenen Plattform entwickelt. Also von den ersten Anfängen, wo die Formel 1 von Ecclestone selbst produziert wurde, bis hin zu dem, was jetzt heute möglicherweise die französische Liga mit einer eigenen Plattform macht. Das ist spannend. Das ändert die Geschäftsmodelle. Die Technologie hat sich geändert. Die Verbreitungswege verändern sich. Das Medienverhalten verändert sich. Und darauf müssen wir jetzt Antworten finden. Und damit müssen wir uns beschäftigen. Und da sind wir, glaube ich, ganz gut aufgestellt, um die Themen dann am Ende mal gemeinsam zu diskutieren. Und dann am Ende muss die DFL und das Präsidium und das Aufsichtsrat dann entscheiden, in welche Richtung es geht.
Haben Sie denn für sich persönlich so einen Best-Case jenseits vom Fußball? Gibt es eine Sportart, eine Liga, die Sie einfach auch deshalb gerne verfolgen, weil der Zugang ein besonderer ist oder ein besonders gut produzierter? Sie sehen es ja wahrscheinlich mit anderen Augen als ich.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die Top-Sportarten, erst wenn wir jetzt, die anderen liegen erst mal dem beim Fußball oder wenn wir andere Sportarten nehmen, wie Tennis oder Golf, die werden schon in einer hohen Qualität produziert. Über Weltmeisterschaften, egal welcher Couleur oder Olympische Spiele, müssen wir nicht reden. Top-Niveau produziert. Also ich glaube schon, dass Top-Sport, Premium-Sport auch Premium-mäßig produziert werden muss. Und dass es am Ende dann in der heutigen Zeit auch nicht kostenlos verfügbar ist, weil es am Ende dann auch nicht finanzierbar ist. Das ist ja klar. Und insofern glaube ich, dass es gibt schon viele Benchmarks, die man sich angucken kann und mit denen wir sprechen, wie die bestimmte Dinge machen, wie die Entwicklungen sehen und so weiter und so fort. Aber wie gesagt, mein Thema hier, unser Thema ist erst mal mehr die Produktion. Und was ist das, was am Ende hinten rauskommen soll? Wie kleinteilig möglicherweise soll es werden? Und das Thema Geschäftsmodell ist das Thema der DFL und Präsidium und Aufsichtsrat.
Ja, das ist ja völlig klar, dass sie werden da jetzt nicht den Weg vorgeben. Weil das möchten sie sicherlich auch gar nicht. Aber ich habe mich eben gefragt, wenn sie jetzt, also das ist jetzt ein sehr fiktives Beispiel, weil da hätten sie am Wochenende Zeit. Ich denke, das würde sehr selten der Fall sein. Aber wenn sie bei sich auf dem Sofa sitzen und sie hätten Zugriff auf alle Streaming-Angebote, NFL, NBA, NHL, MLB, alle liegen und so weiter. Was gucken sie sich dann gerne an, eben auch vor dem Hintergrund, dass sie sagen, boah, die haben tolle Innovationen mit dabei, mir gefällt die Art und Weise, wie das produziert ist, wie ich vielleicht auch darauf zugreifen kann?
Ja, ich versuche mal, Ihre Frage zu deuten. Meine Antwort ist, wir haben so einen breiten Fokus, wir gehen auf Messen, wir gehen auf Veranstaltungen, wir gehen zu anderen Ligen, wir gehen zu anderen Verbänden. Also, ich warte auf den Tag, dass ich vor dem Fernsehen sitze und da wird eine Kamera gezeigt oder eine Einstellung, wo ich denke, die habe ich noch nie gesehen. Den Tag habe ich noch nicht erlebt, weil am Ende ist es so, dass wir alles, das was heute schon ausprobiert wird, wir irgendwo schon mal gesehen haben, ohne dass es live gesendet wurde, weil es einfach ausprobiert wurde und dann gesagt wurde, ja, kann man brauchen oder nicht oder aber ist zu aufwendig, zwar eine schöne Einstellung, aber zu teuer und dies und jenes. Also wir sind da so breit aufgestellt, dass uns eigentlich im Livebetrieb, also wenn uns im Livebetrieb irgendwas überraschen würde, dann würde ich die Kollegen fragen, ob wir vielleicht irgendwo mal nicht aufgepasst hätten.
Und sind sie privat bei TikTok?
Ich bin nur bei WhatsApp.
Okay, Sie müssen zum Glück den Laden hier auch nicht komplett alleine schmeißen. Lassen Sie uns mal kurz die Zeit durchgehen von Ihrer Zeit eben dann Ende Ihrer Karriere. Sie haben ja gerade schon gesagt, wie es so ein bisschen ausgefadet ist, würde ich jetzt mal sagen bei Leverkusen. Und dann, Sie haben ja BWL studiert, eigentlich mit einem Steuer- und Finanzschwerpunkt, wo Sie aber laut eigener Aussage sehr früh gemerkt haben, das ist es dann doch nicht. Sie sind bei der Vigimedia gelandet und haben dann unter anderem das Fanfernsehen, so wie es ich verstanden habe, waren, dass die Einblendungen auf den Stadion-Line wenden für Bremen und für Dortmund, unter anderem produziert. Klären Sie mal, wie ist es denn dazu überhaupt gekommen?
Mir war nach dem Studium und den Fußballspielen klar, also Steuerberater werden möchte ich nicht werden.
Dabei gibt es einige Fußballprofis, die bräuchten das, einen guten Steuerberater.
Ja, aber die wissen ja auch immer alles besser. Also insofern wäre es ein undankbares Feld geworden. Und habe mich dann einfach umgeschaut und habe dann mal gefragt, wer kann denn jemanden brauchen, der Diplomkaufmann ist, zwar keine Berufserfahrung hat, aber vielleicht ein paar andere Kontakte und Ideen hat und so weiter. Und unter anderem war ich auch beim WDR und meine Idee war irgendwie im Finanzwesen, Rechnungswesen als BWL. Aber dann sagte man mir, Volontariat können wir gerne machen, aber in dem Bereich geht eher nicht. Gut, Volontariat war jetzt nicht das, was meine Vorstellung war. Und dann bin ich über RTL, seinerzeit Burkhard Weber. Der hat mir dann gesagt, sprich mal mit der WG Media. Die machen für uns alle Fernsehbetragungen. Das sind Sportmedien, Sportdatenfirma. Die machen auch Vermarktung im Sport. Und ich stelle mal Kontakt hier. Und dann war dort der spätere Sky-Chef, Gaston Schmidt, der dann sagte, ja, können wir uns vorstellen. Ich war mit einem Kollegen bei der WM 94 in den USA und da wurden alle Spiele auf den Screens gezeigt. Und ein oder andere Club kommt jetzt auch schon mit Videowand und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn wir uns einigen, dann ist das ein Projekt zu entwickeln. Das Programm auf den Videowenden mit den Clubs, die immer mehr werden. Und ja, das hat dann gut funktioniert. Werder Bremen war der erste Club, der eine große Videowand hatte.
Willi Lembke damals.
Genau. War auch eine sehr angenehme Zusammenarbeit. Und dann kamen mit und mit Dortmund, die erstmal sagten, wir machen nur Monitore. Wir können das den Fans nicht zumuten, dass die da beschallt werden über eine große Videowand. Aber da machen wir auch ein Programm. Und dann kam der BSC mit Sony und dann FC Bayern München, auch Sony Partner. Und das lief gut an und ja, so war dann der Startschuss in eine Zeit reingerollt, wo das Thema Videowende kam und sie mussten ja auch irgendwie bespielt werden. Und das war sozusagen dann unser Thema, nicht nur großes Fernsehen machen, sondern auch redaktionell kleines Fernsehen machen, um halt eben die halbe Stunde vorm Spiel, Halbzeitnahmspiel ein paar Minuten. Und ja, war eine tolle Zeit, da habe ich sehr viel gelernt. Ich komme ja auch eigentlich nicht aus dem Medienbereich, sondern eher aus dem Zahlenbereich. Aber da lernt man halt eben auch, wie eine Fernsehproduktion funktioniert, im Kleinen. Und kann man dann hochskalieren, ist genau das Gleiche.
Aber das heißt, es war letztlich Learning by Doing, weil mit ihrer Ausbildung hatte es nicht mehr so viel zu tun.
Ja, wenn Sie mich heute fragen, was können Sie von Ihrem Studium, Ihrem Job brauchen? Von allem ein bisschen. Aber ich glaube, dass es viele Skills gibt, die man im normalen Leben auch lernt. Ja, ich glaube auch, das ist ein Teil, ich als Teil einer Fußballmannschaft gelernt habe, wie man sich da verhält und wie man da auftritt. Was mir sicherlich geholfen hat, ist das Zahlenverständnis, die steuerlichen Hintergründe, wie man Buchhaltungen, Bilanzierungen macht und so weiter, sind natürlich alles Themen, die Grundlage sind. Ein Unternehmen kann man auf zwei Weisen verstehen. Auf der einen Seite, indem man sich das Unternehmen einfach anguckt und die Menschen anguckt oder man guckt sich eine Bilanz und Zahlen an, ist in beider Hinsicht etwas beschränkt. Aber es gibt doch einen guten Einblick, wie das Unternehmen dasteht. Und diesen Teil, das ist das, was ich definitiv im Studium mitgenommen habe, was ich aber in jeder anderen Branche genauso hätte mitnehmen können.
Und jetzt sind wir ja jetzt mitten in den 90ern und die sind ja auch gerade aus Fernsehsicht extrem interessant. Ran wird wichtig. Wir haben eben sowas wie Videoleinwände, die kommen. Wir haben aber auch ganz andere Möglichkeiten. Also es gibt aus Mitte der 90er, gibt es zum Teil Interviews, die während des laufenden Spiels mit dem Trainer geführt wurden. Wir haben Otto Rehagel, der als Konkurrent von Bayern, das Spiel von Bayern in Karlsruhe als Experte begleitet und jubelnd auf der Tribüne steht, als das 4 zu 0 für den KSC fährt, weil da Werder in der Torreferenz vorbeigezogen ist an Bayern. Wir haben die FC Hollywood Zeit natürlich, die da mit reinfällt, mit auch einer ganz anderen Darstellung von Spielern als fast schon Popfiguren. Sehen Sie sich manchmal als jemand, der eben für Bilder zuständig ist, zurück in diese 90er, bei denen ich den Eindruck habe, es war ein bisschen auch Wilder Westen, also es hat eins hat doof gesagt, einfach gesagt, wir machen das jetzt so und die Vereine haben gesagt, okay, alles klar, wir lassen es erst mal zu.
Da muss ich einwerfen, zwischen 1995 und 2006 war ich ja bei Vigemedia oder 25 und wir haben dort Formel 1 produziert, Wintersport produziert, Biathlon, Vierchanzentournee, also ich habe ganz viele andere Sportarten gemacht und klar haben wir in der Zeit auch noch Champions League und auch Bundesligaspiele gemacht, aber unter anderem auch das Spiel in Leverkusen mit Christoph Daum, als bekannt wurde, also wo er dann nicht auf der Trainerbank saß. Genau, also das war für mich dann so ein bisschen eine Cooling-down-Phase zum Thema Fußball und ein bisschen andere Sportarten sehen und so weiter und so fort. Also ich habe das mitbekommen, aber als ich dann wieder in die Verantwortung kam 2006, da war ja schon Teil dieser Wildwestzeit schon wieder abgeräumt. Und ich glaube auch, dass wir natürlich uns bemühen, auch jetzt wieder zu sagen, wir müssen näher ans Spiel, näher an die Clubs ran und näher an die Protagonisten ran. Das ist auch gut so. Aber das, was da in der Zeit manchmal gemacht wurde, war schon ein bisschen zu viel, wenn Reporter über den Platz rennen. Also das war schon ein bisschen des Guten zu viel. Deswegen in der Zeit war ich sozusagen nicht komplett in Charge in der Verantwortung, sondern wir haben Übungen dahingestellt und die Clubs und die Bundesliga und die DFL hat gemacht, was sie wollte. Aber die DFL gab es ja noch nicht, es war ja noch alles DFB. Und dann, als ich 25, 26 kam, war es schon deutlich wieder reglementierter.
Liegt ja auch noch eine Kirchinsolvenz dazwischen. Also es war sowieso eine sehr, sehr schwierige Zeit für den deutschen Fußball. Stimmt es denn, dass es letztlich eine E-Mail an Christian Seifert war, die ihre Rolle und auch Sportcast so mit begründet haben?
Ich überleg die ganze Zeit.
Also ich habe gelesen in einem Bericht über sie. Da stand, dass sie 2005 Christian Seifert eine E-Mail geschrieben hätten und gefragt hätten, warum, ob man sich nicht eigene Übertragungswagen zulegen wolle. Und als er dann ein Finanzierungskonzept von ihnen bekommen hat, da kommen wieder die Zahlen zum Vorstein, dann hat er gesagt, okay, machen sie das. Und das ist ja letztlich dann der Startschuss für, wir produzieren nicht nur mit Subunternehmen und Dienstleistern, was jetzt auch immer noch so ist. Also diese horizontale Produktion, auf die sie ja auch gerne verweisen. Aber da hat man das dann selbst in die Hand genommen und ja dann auch die selben Bilder produziert. Das ging ja dann sehr schnell zwischen, ich glaube, Entscheidung 2005 im August und dann im September 2006, die ersten Spieltage, die selbst produziert werden mussten.
Ja, also ich habe eben die ganze Zeit überlegt, wer sie so gut gebrieft hat, wo die Informationen alle herkommen. Aber gut, Fakt war, wir haben bei VegeMedia eine Ausschreibung auf den Tisch bekommen, die aber an verschiedene gegangen ist, weil es gab ja noch eine Produktionsfirma.
War das die Fairplay dann?
Genau und dann habe ich nur gesagt, wir machen der DFL jetzt mal ein Konzept, dass die aufgrund dieses Konzepts vielleicht auch überlegen, es selbst zu machen. Aber nicht alleine dieses Konzept war ausschlaggebend, dass die Liga am Ende dann gesagt hat, wir gründen die Sportcast, sondern auch, weil man sich mit der Fair Play nicht wirklich einigen konnte, wie es weitergeht. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, mein Konzept war jetzt so super, dass Seifert damit gesagt hat, das machen wir jetzt so. Also ich glaube schon, dass das Konzept gut war, aber dass es noch auch andere Dinge im Hintergrund gab, warum man am Ende gesagt hat, wir machen es jetzt. Und die lagen nicht in meiner Hand und die konnte ich auch nicht beeinflussen. Ich glaube, dass Seifert da schon einen klaren Blick hatte, wo er hin wollte und insofern war die Entscheidung für ihn auch richtig. Und wenn man jetzt das mal rückblickend betrachtet, muss man auch sagen, dass das die Grundlage vieler erfolgreicher Ausschreibungen war.
Also der damals öffentlich kommunizierte Grund war, ist ja auch ein nachvollziehbarer. Wenn man selbst die Produktion übernimmt, die eben vorher ganz früher von den Lizenznehmern selbst gemacht wurde, dann ist man ja in Anführungszeichen erpressbar in irgendwelchen Preisverhandlungen. Weil dann könnte der Lizenznehmer auch sagen, ja gut, wenn wir das, das ist aber alles so viel teurer geworden und so teurer Standard, wir können jetzt nicht so viel zahlen.
Also wenn wir diesen Prozess dieses halbe Jahr mal für und wieder und alle Aspekte diskutieren wollen, dann brauchen wir zwei Stunden.
Ich hätte die Zeit. Ich weiß nicht, was ich heute noch vorhabe.
Nein, nein. Also ja, es gab ein gutes Konzept. Es gab Schwierigkeiten mit der alten Gesellschaft. Es gab Vorstellungen, die Seifert gerne umstellen wollte. Und klar, es macht schon viel Sinn, auch nach der Kirchkrise selbst Produzent zu sein. Aber wie gesagt, nochmal, auch wenn die Liga irgendwann sagen würde, wir machen ein eigenes Produkt. Die Komplexität steigt immens. Also der erste Schritt, selbst zu produzieren, dann international das Thema Daten. Alles richtige Schritte, aber die Komplexität steigt. Darüber muss man sich im Klaren sein, dass man dann, wenn man solche Entscheidungen trifft, nicht in der gleichen Struktur und Systematik weiter macht, wie man es vorher gemacht hat. Weil dann wird es nämlich nicht funktionieren. Weil die Komplexität zu beherrschen und am Ende zu steuern, das ist am Ende die Kunst. Ich glaube, dass wir das alle zusammen in den letzten Jahren ganz gut hinbekommen haben.
Hatte das damals auch damit zu tun? Wir hatten ja den TM3 Champions League Deal und dann Arena ist eingestiegen. Völlig überraschend hat sich die Lizenz gesichert. Es gab aber gleichzeitig dann eine heiße Debatte und auch nach allem, was ich so recherchieren konnte, auch Vorstöße von Sky. Oder damals noch Premiere? In Zusammenarbeit mit T-Online, tatsächlich über IPTV und über das Internet. Dann entsprechend doch ein Produkt an den Endkunden zu bekommen, der dann vielleicht gar nicht mehr den Unterschied hat, ob er jetzt hier einen Arena-Receiver sich gerade hingestellt hat mit Kabel und Satellit oder eben ein anderes Produkt. Hat das damit reingespielt, dass es da ja auch große Verwirrung gab tatsächlich?
Also ohne eine Sportcast-Produktion hätte Arena gar nicht einsteigen können.
Weil sie es nicht hätten stemmen können.
Genau, genau. Und das war der Punkt, was Seifert gesehen hat. Ich kann neue Interessenten für die Bundesliga begeistern, wenn die nur, in Anführungsstrichen, Signal abgreifen müssen. Genau, Abspielplattformen sind. Dann gab es ein paar Abgrenzungsprobleme, die zu heftigen Verwirrungen geführt haben. Was ist IPTV und was ist das, was Arena macht und so weiter und so fort, die ja auch keine, nicht direkt eine Satellitenplattform machen wollten. Das war eine schwierige Zeit, wo auch Seifert, glaube ich, sehr gefordert war, das irgendwie alles in der Luft zu halten. Das hat er am Ende geschafft. Arena ist dann relativ schnell wieder raus. Sky ist wieder rein. Das war eine schwierige Zeit. Und am Ende, so nach einem Jahr oder anderthalb Jahren hat Seifert dann, oder zwei Jahren hat Seifert mal gesagt, wenn er vorher gewusst hätte, wie kompliziert und schwierig das alles ist, dann hätte er es vielleicht nicht gemacht. Aber dann wären wir auch nicht auf den Mond geflogen.
Ja, das ist natürlich wahr. Aber das hat ja für sie bedeutet, dass sie innerhalb kürzester Zeit eben das auf die Beine stellen mussten. Also ich stelle mir die WM 2006 aus ihren Augen komplett anders vor als aus den Augen der sonstigen Bevölkerung, die wirklich Zeit hatte, da Fußball zu gucken. Und sie mussten innerhalb weniger Monate die Produktion von, ich weiß gerade gar nicht wie viel, aber es waren über 600, glaube ich, Bundesligaspiele damals organisieren.
Heute 617 mit Relegation und Supercup. Also ich könnte mich dem Satz von Seifert anschließen. Ich war so davon überzeugt, dass man das in drei Monaten an den Start bringt. Ich hatte gar keinen Zweifel. Und den darf man auch da nicht haben, weil ich natürlich auch auf bestehende Strukturen, ich wusste wenig, anspreche, kannte ja alles. Das war, glaube ich, der entscheidende Punkt. Wir haben im April 2006 nichts gehabt. Kein Büro, gar nichts.
Kein Übertragungswagen?
Ja, die gab es ja. Also klar, die haben ja darauf gewartet, dass sie Aufträge kriegen. Also das waren ja gleich Übertragungswagen, die vorher auch schon da waren. Also das gab ja alles. Es musste nur alles neu sortiert werden. Aber wir hatten im April 2006 hatten wir nichts. Ich habe drüben in Deutz, in einem Hotel, habe ich alle Gespräche geführt. Also das war mein Beruf. Und es hat auch alles gut funktioniert. Ein Punkt, der hätte uns fast das Genick gebrochen. Die FIFA hatte alle Stadien, also alle WM-Stadien, umgebaut, verkabelt und nichts zurückgebaut. Und am ersten Spieltag kommen die Ü-Wagen-Dienstleister an. Kabel zur Pressetubüne, Kabel von der Pressetubule runter, Kabel zum Innenraum. Nichts, nichts klappt da mehr. Gelsenkirchen, Katastrophe.
Deswegen waren die ersten drei Spieltage so holprig? Ja. Ah ja.
Und dann mussten wir los und gucken, wie kriegen wir das eigentlich? Also das, wenn keine WM gewesen wäre, wäre es ein Traumstart gewesen. Das war eine Katastrophe. Also das, die ersten drei Spieltage haben wirklich, das war ein Horror. Das war wirklich ein Horror. Aber die haben wir dann auch geschafft.
Gut, und man hat dann auch das öffentliche Echo ausgehalten. Sie haben ja vorhin schon angesprochen, also es ist jetzt schon so lange her, dass man sich nicht mehr so dran erinnert. Aber es war damals schon ein großes Thema. Eben auch der Zensurvorwurf, der ja bis heute kommt. Sie haben es ja vorhin schon angesprochen.
Also ich höre den nicht mehr.
Okay, das ist ja, das ist ja.
Also in unseren Gesprächen mit den Lizenznehmern, dieser Vorwurf kommt nicht, weil er auch absurd ist, weil jeder im Stadion seine eigene Geschichte schreiben kann.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich auch gar nicht auf das Thema zurück. Aber es war quasi damals ein öffentlich wirklich auch bemerkenswertes Thema. Aber es ist ein bisschen in der WM untergegangen. Also das ist das, was ich eben meinte. Wie viele WM-Spiele haben sie denn überhaupt gesehen können?
Ja, ich kann mich auf jeden Fall als Öffnungsspiel erinnern, wo wir auf der Gegend gerade in der Sonne gesessen haben und zerlaufen sind, weil es so heiß war. Aber es war ein tolles Spiel. Und ich auch da vor dem Gespräch, vor dem Spiel noch Gespräche in München geführt habe und so weiter. Also, dass die WM in Deutschland war, war schon irgendwie für uns ein guter Schirm. Also, da konnten wir darunter arbeiten. Nur die Konsequenz, dass die FIFA die Stadien hinterlassen hat, also komplett anders als sie vorher dahingekommen sind, das war für uns das Problem.
Und gleichzeitig fällt aber ja auch die Gründung der Sportcast und die ersten Jahre zusammen mit einer Neubelebung des deutschen Fußballs, was die Infrastruktur angeht. Also wir haben eben jetzt dann eben fertige WM-Stadien und auch wenn die FIFA da nicht zurückgebaut hat, irgendwann hatte man dann die eigenen Kabel wieder gelegt. Und dann hatte man ja auch Zugriff auf bessere Arbeitsbedingungen als zuvor.
Definitiv. Aber da muss man auch sagen, das geht nur Hand in Hand. Also das, was ein Club mit einem Keterer macht oder weiß ich was, das geht uns alles nicht an. Nichts an. Aber das, was man braucht, um eine Medienproduktion durchzuführen und dabei schon freie Stromversorgung, Kamerastandard, Kabel, Übergangsstellplatz und und und. Also das muss man einfach sagen in der Zusammenarbeit mit den Clubs. Das ist in den ganzen Jahren wirklich sehr, sehr gut gewesen, weil irgendwann haben die auch verstanden, dass wir da arbeiten und nicht einfach nur zum Spass hinkommen.
Also wenn wir dann eben auf diese Anfangszeit blicken und jetzt haben sie ja schon gesagt, okay, dann so ab dem vierten Spieltag, dann lief alles und irgendwann glaube ich, durfte es aus dem Hotel rausgehen, einmal über den Rhein drüber und dann in neue Räumlichkeiten. Wie war denn so diese Anfangsphase und wie schnell ist dann auch zum Beispiel das Team der Sportcast gewachsen?
Also das Team war relativ schnell, stand das aus Leuten, die ich halt eben kannte, die in dem Bereich schon gearbeitet hatten, die von der Wiege kamen, die ich aus meinem Netzwerk kannte und so weiter. Das haben wir relativ schnell und gut hinbekommen und dann mussten wir ein bisschen nachjustieren und so weiter. Aber wie gesagt, nach dem dritten Spieltag und nochmal, also ich will mich da auch nicht rausreden, das war mit oder mit einer anderen Erfahrung hätte man das vielleicht ahnen können. Aber ich hatte keine Ahnung.
Was waren denn so die größten Probleme? Können Sie das mal kurz sagen?
Ja, dass die sozusagen eine komplett andere Verkabelung gemacht hatten.
Und wie hat es dann der Zuschauer und die Zuschauerin gemerkt? Woran?
Indem Signale falsch ankamen, der Ton nicht da war, die Interviews nicht da waren. Das war ein Chaos. Das kriegen sie als Ü-Wagen-Dienstleister an dem Tag nicht mehr geregelt. Dann haben sie so viele Baustellen, das finden sie nicht an dem Tag. Da müssen sie jedes Kabel durchgehen. Ja, was steht da? A nach B. A, okay. Ist B auch B oder ist B C? Das war so ein Durcheinander. Und in mehreren Stadien. Und am Anfang haben wir gedacht, was machen die da? Also die kennen doch die Stadien, die Ü-Wagen. Und bis dass sie dann mal alles, weiß ich noch, wenn Stefan Ziehmann sagte nach dem dritten Spieltag, Jupp, jetzt muss es funktionieren. Und dann hat es funktioniert. Und das war das am Ende auch, was vielleicht Seifert vielleicht meinte. Aber das hatten wir nicht auf dem Schirm, das konnten wir nicht auf dem Schirm haben. Und danach war auch nie mehr ein Thema. Also er hat auch nie einmal zu mir gesagt, dass er mal gedacht hätte, das wäre ein Fehler oder sonst irgendwas. Und wir haben dann überlegt, wir haben dann nach vorne geguckt, dann gesagt, was können wir denn tun, um eine Akzeptanz zu haben gegenüber den Medienpartnern? Was können wir denn machen? Und dann haben wir uns überlegt, wir machen mal ein sogenanntes Innovationsspiel. Das haben wir dann in Düsseldorf gemacht, ein Innovationsspiel. Da haben wir unsere Dienstleister eingeladen, unsere Lizenznehmer eingeladen, Broadcast-Unternehmen eingeladen. Wir haben gesagt, zeigt uns mal, wir machen ein Fußballspielchen oder zwei Fußballspielchen mit Jugendmannschaften. Was kann man anders machen? Habt ihr andere Kammerperspektiven? Können wir irgendwas beim Schnitt anders machen? Können wir irgendwas irgendwo, irgendeine Idee und haben da so ein Tages-Event draus gemacht. Und das fanden alle klasse. Das gab es ja gar nicht. Wir kommen alle mal zusammen. Wir reden alle wie eine kleine Messe. Und das war eine gute Idee. Das haben wir dann zwei Mal gemacht. Und daraus ist dann die Sports Innovation geworden. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie die kennen, die Veranstaltung von der DF. Daraus ist die Sports Innovation geworden. Natürlich dann die Innovationsspiele waren Sport, Gas, Grün. Innovationsspiel ist DFL Rot ist ja auch richtig so. Das war also der Ansatz. Und damit haben wir dann sozusagen, glaube ich, den letzten Durchbruch geschafft, dass wir akzeptiert wurden, dass wir die 600 Spiele machen. Da haben die Lizenznehmer nichts mehr zu tun. Die können uns sagen, wenn sie was gerne anders hätten, im Regieleitfaden, im Schnitt oder sonst irgendwas. Aber eigentlich können sie sich auf das Redaktionelle konzentrieren, auf ihre Themen, auf ihre Geschichten. Und ich vermute mal, dass das auch bis heute so von den Lizenznehmern gesehen wird.
Weil sie gerade gesagt haben, grün und rot, das ist jetzt nur so ein kleines Nebenthema. Aber warum wird da nicht besser darauf geachtet, dass Leute mit rot-grün Sehschwäche in der Bundesliga, die Mannschaften unterscheiden müssen? Weil sie haben ja bestimmt auch in ihrem Team oder in den Ü-Wagens und so weiter, da sitzen ja auch Leute mit rot-grün Sehschwäche. Jeder zehnte Deutsche ist davon, glaube ich, betroffen.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann es dir nicht sagen. Für meine Begriffe, ich weiß nicht, ist das so verbreitet?
Ja, das ist viel verbreiteter, als man glaubt.
Ja, das wusste ich jetzt nicht. Aber das ist ein Thema, der einen Spiel betrieb.
Ja, genau. Es greift ja alles ineinander. Vielleicht ist auch nicht immer die Zuständigkeit so klar, auch wenn sie vielleicht klar sein sollte, auf dem Papier. Und dann bleibt sowas, glaube ich, auch manchmal hängen im Produktionsablauf.
Am Ende ist die DFL auch eine Interessevertretung, die so viele unterschiedliche Themen händeln muss und dann gleichzeitig auch noch operativ arbeiten muss. Das ist manchmal auch schwierig.
Können Sie denn mal den Hörern und Hörern beschreiben, was die Sportcast und ja auch die unter GmbHs, die es dazu gibt, die unter Unternehmen, was die jetzt eigentlich alles machen an so einem Bundesligaspieltag?
Also wir nennen uns offiziell koordinierender Dienstleister. Wir koordinieren an einem Spieltag alle 18 Spiele der 1. und 2. Liga, um ein fertiges Fernsehbild zu machen, das sogenannte Basissignal. Dazu bereiten wir vor eine Ü-Wagenplanung. Also wir buchen Übertragungswagen, große, kleine, mittlere. Wir buchen die Regisseure, Kameraleute, Slo-Mo-Operator, Aufnahmeleiter, alles, was dazu kommt. Dann sagen uns die Lizenznehmer, in der Regel Sky und The Zone, was sie vor Ort machen wollen und auch ARD und ZDF. Und dann kriegen die halt eben ihr technisches Setup, um ein Spiel live zu kommentieren und eine Moderation vorher zu machen. Die ARD bekommt einen Schnitt dazugestellt, das ZDF bekommt einen Schnitt dazugekommt, gestellt als Nachverwerter. Also wir planen erstmal das ganze Setup im Stadion, damit alle arbeiten können und ein Fernsehsignal, ein Barsignal und auch die unilateralen Leistungen für Sky, The Zone und so weiter, dass die dort abgewickelt werden können. Dann sind wir im Stadion erstmal fertig. Dann stellen wir die Signale, das fertige Fernsehsignal auf den Satelliten, damit die Lizenznehmer, vor allen Dingen auch die internationalen, aber auch teilweise die Landesrundfunk und Stadtarzt national, das Signal vom Satelliten abgreifen können, damit sie auch die 90 Minuten Spielbild haben. Dieses 90 Minuten Spielbild senden wir auch gleichzeitig hier nach Köln, wo wir seit 2006 mit RTL schrägstisch Tochterfirma CBC zusammenarbeiten, die für uns in Zusammenarbeit auch mit unserer Schwestergesellschaft DS das internationale Produktportfolio erstellen, also die Live-Spiele...
Also die SS Digital Solutions?
Digital Sports.
Digital Sports, genau.
Und die dort die Live-Spiele kommentieren, eigentlich die die Highlights schneiden für eine internationale Sportschau. Und diese Signale werden dann auch weltweit distribuiert an alle Lizenznehmer, die das Recht haben. Per Satellit, per Stream, per Glasfaser. Sodass wir eine Wertschöpfungskette haben, von aus dem Stadion nach aus bis hin zum internationalen Lizenznehmer, der es dann an seine Endkunden, wo auch immer auf der Welt, weitergibt. Das ist im Grunde genommen sozusagen das operative Tätigkeitsfeld. Daneben haben wir, betreiben wir aber auch noch das Media Hub, das digitale Archiv, was einerseits zentraler Knotenpunkt für die internationale Produktion ist und gleichzeitig unser Gedächtnis, unser Bildergedächtnis.
Der Schatz der Bundesliga.
Genau, der Schatz der Bundesliga. Und daneben gibt es noch die Sportex Solutions, die wir 2016 gegründet haben, wo die Daten erhoben werden. Checking, Scouting und auch Speicher, weil die Daten, die wir da rausbekommen, wenn sie denn hundertprozentig stimmen, legen wir über ein Bild, also über die 90 Minuten. Und wenn ich dann sage, zeigt mir den dritten Eckball, dann springt er auf den dritten Eckball und ich sehe den Eckball in einer Sequenz von 30 Sekunden beispielsweise. Das ist halt eben der Vorteil, wenn die Daten erhoben werden für den Spielbetrieb und sonst irgendwas, dafür können wir die auch brauchen und müssen das nicht nochmal separat tracken, weil die Daten, Eckball, Pass, Tor und so weiter vorgegeben ist. Und die müssen natürlich stimmen, wenn sie sagen, zeigt mir den siebten Eckball, aber es hat nur sechs Eckbälle gegeben, dann haben sie natürlich ein Problem. Den finden sie dann nicht mehr.
Also das zeigt eben quasi, wie breit inzwischen das Angebot ist. Gleichzeitig ist die Geschichte dieser einzelnen Unternehmen für sich genommen nochmal. Also da könnte man alleine eine Stunde dran verbringen, weil oft ging es mit einem Partner los, data, dreh und so weiter und so fort. Dann hat sich weiterentwickelt. Und gleichzeitig landen wir aber immer bei dem Punkt, dass es logischerweise aus Sicht der DFL und der dahinterstehenden Vereine sehr wichtig ist, Zugriff auf das eigene Produkt zu haben. Wir haben hier einen Sport, der soll als Unterhaltungsprodukt dargestellt werden. Und dann haben wir ganz, ganz viele verschiedene Ansatzpunkte, auch sportliche. Also Trackingdaten werden ja auch von den Vereinen für natürlich den eigentlichen Kern, nämlich den Sport, verwendet. Aber es geht eigentlich immer darum, dieses Produkt bestmöglich darzustellen. Jetzt haben sie schon von der Sports Innovation gesprochen und von den Innovationsspielen. Also die Hörerinnen und Hörer werden das bestimmt auch schon mal gesehen haben. Zum Beispiel hat man da zum ersten Mal eine Revcam gesehen oder man hat, ich glaube, Spidercams, das waren doch die ganz frühen Innovationsspiele, wurden da zum ersten Mal gezeigt.
Oder fahrende Kameras.
Fahrende Kameras, genau. Die so ein bisschen wie in so einer Videospiel-Simulation immer so halb auf Höhe des Balls sind. Das sind immer wieder so Dinge, die man da sehen kann. Wie schafft man es denn dann, diese Innovationen ins Produkt zu übernehmen? Die Lizenznehmer äußern wahrscheinlich Wünsche und dann müssen sie das ja auch auf Grundlage der Qualitätsstandards, die sehr hoch sind bei der Sportcast, integrieren ins neue Portfolio, sage ich mal.
Ja, es gibt natürlich viele Vorschläge und nur wenige schaffen es dann tatsächlich auch ins offizielle Programm. Es gibt halt eben auch Benchmarks. Was ich eben schon mal gesagt habe, wir schauen uns andere Ligen an, wir gehen auf Messen, wir arbeiten seit vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren für die FIFA und für die UEFA bei Weltmeisterschaften, Europameisterschaften und so weiter. Das heißt, wir kriegen so viel Input, was gut ist und was nicht gut ist und wo wir uns darum kümmern müssen. Also insofern, das ist ein laufender Prozess, da ist jetzt nicht einer drauf angesetzt, zu sagen, ich gucke jetzt überall mal, wo ich was finde. Nein, das ist ein permanentes auf Messe gehen, andere mit anderen Verbänden reden, mit anderen Organisationen reden und so weiter. Das wir und wir hatten uns 2006 sozusagen unseren eigenen Leitsatz formuliert und der besteht nur aus drei Worten. Qualität, Nachhaltigkeit, Innovation. Das sind unsere drei Maxime. Qualität ist klar, Nachhaltigkeit war aber jetzt nicht in dem Sinne ökologische Nachhaltigkeit, sondern Nachhaltigkeit im Sinne von, wenn zwei miteinander arbeiten, müssen beide was davon haben. Also wenn wir Partnerschaften eingehen, Dienstleister, dann nur wenn das auch langfristig angelegt ist, wenn beide was davon haben. Das war unser Begriff der Nachhaltigkeit. Der hat sich natürlich heute gewandelt und den kann man auch anders anwenden. Alles gut. Und der dritte Begriff war Innovation. Wir sind ja, das muss man deutlich sagen, wir sind ja Monopolist. Die DFL gibt die Aufträge an uns und die Lizenznehmer müssen es von uns nehmen. Im ersten Augenblick ist das eine sehr komfortable Situation. Aber wenn sie Monopolist sind und den Wettbewerb nicht im Blick haben, dann können sie nur verlieren. Und deswegen sage ich hier unseren Kollegen und Kolleginnen immer, wir müssen besser sein als die anderen, weil der Monopolist hilft uns nicht. Der macht uns nur träge. Wir müssen uns selbst den Wettbewerb suchen, damit niemand auf die Idee kommt und sagt, jetzt suchen wir uns mal jemand anders. Bei Sportcast, die sind nicht richtig gut drauf. Und deswegen ist die Situation als Monopolist schwieriger, als jemand, der permanent im Wettbewerb ist, weil wir uns im Wettbewerb immer suchen müssen. Und wenn ich jetzt sage, dass wir bei der Club WM im Sommer zwei Teams aus Deutschland schicken und wahrscheinlich ein Team auch mit unserem Regisseur dann das Finale macht, dann weiß ich, wir sind eigentlich auf einem guten Weg. Und das ist sozusagen das, was wir immer wieder, was wir immer allen sagen, wir haben einen tollen Job und wir haben eine tolle Muttergesellschaft und wir haben tolle Clubs. Aber wir müssen aus dieser Position des Monopolisten, die dürfen wir nicht annehmen, sondern wir müssen uns unseren Wettbewerb selbst suchen und messen. Und das funktioniert eigentlich jetzt schon fast 20 Jahre ganz gut.
Aber woran liegt das dann, dass ich, dass man bei anderen Ligen eine komplett andere Richtung wahrnehmen kann, wie sich die Übertragung verändert? Also ein kleines Beispiel zum Beispiel, La Liga zeigt Grafiken gerne auch mal auf dem Spielfeld ein. Also da wird dann so und so viele Prozent der Ecken kamen, selbst zuletzt in den Rückraum, solche kamen an den ersten Pfosten. La Liga ist zum Beispiel auch sehr gut darin, strittige Entscheidungen noch während des Live-Spiels in einem Splitscreen zu zeigen. Nur mal als ein Beispiel.
Ja, also ich glaube, dass die La Liga da auf einem ganz guten Weg ist mit ihrer La Liga Tech. Die haben ja eine eigene Firma, die sich um die ganzen Themen, die neben dem Basissignal passieren, haben die eine eigene Firma. Man kann darüber streiten, ob der Splitscreen gut ist oder nicht.
Also ich finde ihn super. Ich muss nicht auf die Unterbrechung warten, bis ich das faul sehe. Ich kann ja entscheiden, hat die Zuschauer, wo ich hingucken will.
Das stimmt. Ich finde es nicht gut, weil ich finde, es gibt immer noch Zeit genug, die Szene zu zeigen. Aber das ist eine Philosophiefrage. Der dritte Punkt ist, wenn sie sagen, sie gucken schon mal unser internationales Signal, es ist natürlich schon ein Unterschied zwischen dem internationalen und dem nationalen Signal. Und ich weiß auch nicht, ob das, was die La Liga international macht, ob das auch das nationale Signal ist.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist nicht immer gleich.
So, am Ende ist es so, über die Dinge kann man diskutieren. Und muss man auch diskutieren. Darüber müssen wir, wir geben so eine Richtung vor. Aber letztendlich die Entscheidung trifft die DFL. Wenn wir jetzt solche Themen diskutieren, ob wir Grafiken machen, ob wir die Einblendung machen, den Splitscreen oder was auch immer wir machen, das müssen wir diskutieren. Dann wird es entschieden. Ich kann nicht in den Dinge selbst entscheiden. Das wäre, glaube ich, der falsche Weg, weil die Produktur liegt bei der DFL. Und das müssen wir eben diskutieren. Und wenn es so Themen sind, dann ist einfach die Frage. Es gibt auch sogenannte Editors Workshops. Da werden die Lizenznehmer, auch die Internationalen, eingeladen und die werden gefragt, was wollt ihr haben? Und wenn solche Sachen dann nicht kommen von denen, würde ich es auch nicht machen. Weil dafür sind diese Workshops ja da. Also man kann über viele Themen diskutieren und wir kennen auch glaube ich fast alle Themen. Aber man muss sich halt eben damit auseinandersetzen.
Und wurde dann in solchen Editors Workshops gesagt, wir wollen jetzt die Busankunft haben? Weil das so verkauft wurde, als wir sind näher dran am Spiel und so weiter, mit der Neuinrechte vergabelt.
Also wir kommen jetzt in so einen Bereich, in dem ich eigentlich hier meinen Platz tauschen müsste und jemand von der DFL sich hier hinsetzen müsste. Weil die Produkturheit und die ganzen Thematiken liegen erstmal bei der DFL. Und also ich will mich da jetzt auch nicht distanzieren. Ja, also oder sagen, die machen das nicht gut. Ganz im Gegenteil. Aber letztendlich, das sind die Themen, inhaltliche Themen, die dort diskutiert werden müssen. Und ob ich jetzt eine Busankunft mache oder nicht. Also ich finde eine Busankunft bei einem 1830 Spiel mit einem längeren Vorlauf, finde ich das gut. Bei einem 1530 Spiel vor der Konferenz, das macht keinen Sinn. Also meiner Sicht. So und die Themen muss man dann diskutieren, wo man was macht.
Ja das interessante ist ja der eigentliche Kern. Das Spiel ist auch insofern der eigentliche Kern, weil es einen klaren Einschalt- und Ausschaltpunkt für die FernsehkonsumentInnen gibt. Also mehr oder weniger die breite Masse wird zum Anpfiff einschalten, wird in der Halbzeit sich weg vom Fernseher bewegen, in der Regel oder vom Abspielgerät. Und relativ schnell nach Abpfiff ist es auch wieder vorbei. Und das drückt sich ja auch in dem 5-2-2-5-Rundown, der so der Standard ist. Also fünf Minuten vorm Spiel gehen wir rein, zwei Minuten in die Halbzeit reingehen wir ab und zwei Minuten vor der Halbzeit wieder raus.
Beide Sohnen haben sie gar nicht mehr Zeit.
Ja, das ist jetzt noch mein eigenes Thema. Aber da will ich sie jetzt nicht in unangenehme Situationen bringen, weil das ist wirklich ja nicht ihre Verantwortung, was da kommt. Aber das bedeutet ja letztlich, das ist ja interessant und eigentlich ja auch eine gute Nachricht, dass das Spiel offenbar im Interesse von allen im Fokus steht. Also sowohl von denjenigen, die das Produkt Bundesliga konsumieren, dann logischerweise bei denen, die es ausführen. Aber ja auch bei ihnen, die das Ganze produzieren. Und jetzt habe ich zum Beispiel gelesen, 2019 gab es da mal eine kleinere Debatte darüber, dass in der Premier League viel häufiger geschnitten wurde, oder seltener geschnitten wurde, Entschuldigung, als während eines Bundesligaspiels. Also in der Premier League waren es damals 500 Schnitte pro Spiel, in der La Liga und in der Bundesliga so aufgerundet 700. Und damals habe ich gelesen, dass sie da auch immer wieder Testpennis durchführen. Können sie mal erzählen, was sie alles tun hier bei Sportcast und den ganzen Tochterunternehmen, um eben festzustellen, sind wir noch am Puls der Sehgewohnheit?
Also wir benchmarken natürlich die anderen Ligen, die Engländer, die Spanier, die Italiener, die Franzosen. Und natürlich gibt es Unterschiede. Der eine macht vier kurze Slow Mo's, der eine macht drei lange Slow Mo's. Und man kann es ja in vieler Hinsicht machen. Oder wie mache ich einen Abstoß? Mache ich einen Abstoß immer aus der Eins? Mache ich den aus der Flach?
Also der Führungskamera?
Ja, aus der Führungskamera. Mache ich einen Abstoß von der Hintertor hoch? Oder mache ich ihn aus der Spidercam? Oder mache ich ihn von hinten? Es gibt ja ganz viele Möglichkeiten. Nur das diskutieren wir und das schauen wir uns an. Wer macht das? Wer macht das? Wer macht das? Und dann führen wir auch Panels durch, wo wir mit der Sporto-Schule Spiele beobachten lassen. Und lassen die benoten oder bewerten oder auch begutachten, was war gut, was war nicht gut, was haben die da gemacht, da gemacht. Das ist das Thema Benchmarking. Da wissen wir eigentlich ganz gut Bescheid. Und am Ende ist es auch so, dass so, wie wir es seit über 15 Jahren machen, auch irgendwann die UEFA und die FIFA hat damit angefangen. Weil wir gesagt haben, wenn wir fünf Spiele am Nachmittagringer Konferenz haben, dann sollte die Art und Weise zu schneiden auch gleich sein. Also der eine macht nicht fünf Slomos und der andere macht zwei Slomos. Und der eine macht das und der andere macht das. Sondern wir wollen schon ein Look and Feel haben, was für alle gleich ist. Damit wenn du umschaltest nicht denkst, was das ist. Das ist ein anderer Liga, aber es ist ein anderes Spiel. So und das hat die FIFA und die UEFA auch irgendwann übernommen und hat ihren Regisseuren, die aus Spanien kommen, aus England kommen, Frankreich kommen, jeder hat gemacht, wie er es zu Hause macht. Und dann haben die gesagt, okay, das ist ja eine gute Idee. Lass uns noch mal so einen Regieleitfaden definieren. Wie wollen wir es denn haben? Wir können es ja diskutieren, ob wir drei kurze Slomos oder vier, keine Ahnung, oder zwei, oder wie auch immer, oder aus verschiedenen Perspektiven, wie viele flache Kameras wollen wir und so weiter und so fort. Und das alles untersuchen wir und diskutieren das am Ende auch intern und auch mit unseren Lizenznehmern. Und wenn man dann sieht, die Franzosen haben immer so Slomo-Pakete.
Ich sehe schon, sie sind kein Fan.
Kann man darüber diskutieren. Die Engländer haben den Vorteil, die haben natürlich abgeflachte Rasen. Sie haben immer Fans im Hintergrund. Immer Fans im Hintergrund.
Bei Deutschland jetzt schon zwei LED-Banden übereinander. Der erste Fan in acht Metern Höhe.
Genau, was machen wir denn dann? Also machen wir flache Kameras, die so zeigen. Die Engländer machen die eins, die Führungskammer von oben, den Rasen. Die haben immer Fans im Bild. Und natürlich machen die dann, steigen die dann noch weniger. Und wir nehmen die flachen mehr ein. Also wir diskutieren alles. Alles. Und stimmen uns dann ab und versuchen, ein bestmögliches Produkt zu machen. Das ist nicht so, als wenn da einer hingeht und sich mit den Kameraläuten und Slow-Mop-Operätern trifft und sagt, heute machen wir mal ein schönes Spiel. Das Spiel ist natürlich auch davon abhängig. Ist es ein schnelles Spiel? Fallen mehr Tore? Haben wir ein langweiles Spiel? Ich weiß gar nicht. Ich würde mir gerne Zeitlupe zeigen, aber es ist nichts zum Zeitlupe zeigen. Wir diskutieren alles. Das ist wirklich, wirklich. Ich würde jetzt sagen, nicht hochwissenschaftlich, aber es ist wissenschaftlich, wie wir es machen. Wir versuchen, unsere Themen, Emotionalität, den Sport, das reinzubringen. Und natürlich müssen wir auch unsere Lizenznehmer fragen. Seid ihr damit einverstanden? Und funktioniert das für euch so? Das ist also ein umfangreiches Feld.
Aber wenn da so viel Herzblut reinfließt, wie sehr blutet dann ihr Herz, wenn dann ein Lizenznehmer, um noch mal eine Kryptowerbung einzublenden, eine eigene Zeitlupe einfach so drüber schmeißt aufs Signal und dabei nicht immer das perfekte Timing hat?
Da schweigt das Sängershöflichkeit.
Gut, wir können uns die Antwort dann daraus denken. Ich verstehe, dass, was Sie beschrieben haben, sehr gut, dass man eine Wiedererkennbarkeit haben möchte. Und vor allem rüstet man sich ja damit auch für alle möglichen Gegebenheiten. Also in der Regieanweisung steht da nicht drin, in Minute 1,37 bitte auf die 1, sondern da steht da drin, wir wollen in der Regel, wenn ein Abstoß ausgeführt wird, sobald der Ball getreten wird, soll es die 1 sein.
Nein, da steht drin, dass wir verschiedene Perspektiven haben wollen, dass wir ein bisschen abwechslungsreich werden wollen, dass wir auch, wir wollen auch Gesichter zeigen und wir wollen auch, wenn ein toller Trick, wenn Florian Wirz wieder dreimal die Hacke, das wollen wir sehen und so weiter. Aber am Ende, das Wichtigste ist immer, wir wollen das Spiel zeigen. Wir wollen das Spiel zeigen. Wenn der Ball rollt, sind wir auf dem Platz.
Und da haben wir ja mehrere Schwierigkeiten. Also das eine ist, dass so eine gewisse Konformität, also eine Stringenz dann in der Übertragung, aber auch eine Austauschbarkeit erschafft. Also dadurch, dass ich, ich gucke ja pro Spieltag jedes Spiel. Und deswegen kann ich Ihnen wahrscheinlich aus dem Kopf ungefähr genau die Schnittfolge sagen, die wir immer haben von die beiden Kapitäne mit dem Schiedsrichter im Anstoßkreis und so weiter und so fort.
Aber das sind ja die Rituale, die sie in allen Liegen gleich haben. Ja, also es geht ums Spiel und deswegen sage ich ja, man könnte jetzt sagen, es hat eine gewisse formalen Hang, aber jedes Spiel ist ja anders. Jedes Spiel läuft anders.
Also ich muss sagen, so von der Produktion her, ich finde es halt einfach interessant, dass es so erkennbare Unterschiede gibt. Und ich will das jetzt gar nicht wertend meinen, weil dafür gucke ich zu wenig andere Liegen. Ich bin so auf Bundesliga fixiert, dass ich es aber zum Beispiel fällt mir, wenn ich Premier League spiele, neben schaue, dann fällt mir eben neben der anderen Kameraposition durch die abgeflachten Rasen und so weiter, was Sie gerade schon angesprochen haben. Es fällt mir vor allem auch auf, dass die Audioproduktion anders zu sein scheint.
Das ist unheimlich wuchtig und das ist jetzt wieder das Thema international.
Das heißt, national hören die es auch, hört es sich für die auch anders an oder?
Genau.
Aber warum?
Ganz einfach. Der nationale Kommentator sitzt offen im Stadion. Der internationale sitzt in Köln in der Kabine. Und natürlich kriege ich eine ganz andere Kulisse rüber, wenn ich den Kommentator in eine Kabine setze und nehme nur den Ton, die Atmosphäre, als wenn ich im Stadion bin und die Atmosphäre gegen die Stimme des Kommentators arbeitet. Okay. Und deswegen sage ich jedem, wer den wirklichen Ton mal hören will, muss entweder auf dem Übergang gehen oder zur CBC oder das internationale Bild sich anhören. Und wir kriegen ja umgekehrt den...
Ja klar, das verstehe ich. Dass wir dann quasi den Sutton Premier League Sound mitbekommen. Ehrlicherweise, es hat auch manchmal mit Colourgrading ein bisschen zu tun, aber da bin ich mir immer nicht so ganz sicher, ob man sich das nicht auch manchmal ein bisschen einbildet. Also in Liverpool sieht der Rasen immer supergrün aus und die Trikots sind superrot, wenn man keine rot-grünscht.
Aber deswegen machen wir ja auch hier in Köln Signalkontrolle, damit wir die Farben ein bisschen abgleichen. Also das heißt jetzt nicht, dass wir einen anderen Farbton machen, aber dass das ein wenig abgeglichen ist, wenn man von einem Stadion zum anderen schaltet.
Wer da mal sehen will, wie es auch sein könnte, der kann Frauenbundesliga gucken, wird nicht von Sportcast produziert usw. Da sieht das völlig unterschiedlich aus.
Ja, das ist aber auch ein anderer Ansatz.
Und andere Möglichkeiten. Also es soll jetzt auch kein Diss sein, aber nur einfach, das ist einfach der Unterschied, den man sieht. Und gleichzeitig haben sie ja aber auch noch die Herausforderung. Sie produzieren ja auch das Signal, was die Schiedsrichterinnen und Schiedsrichter im Videokeller sich ansehen. Stimmt es eigentlich, dass es ein ehemaliger Dekoraum ist, der einfach dann spontan, relativ spontan zum Körner Keller wurde?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich war gestern drüben, es sieht ein bisschen so aus, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist schon sehr eng.
Der Punkt ist natürlich, ich kann den Video Schiedsrichter zentral und dezentral machen. Dezentral heißt, ich bin mit den Autos komplett im Stadion oder ich mach's zentral und da brauche ich ein Glasfasernetz, was wir haben und alle Signale in Köln. So, insofern kam als einziger Standort ja nur der Standort in Frage, wo sowieso alle Signale ankommen wegen der internationalen Produktion. Und so ist der Standort festgemacht worden. Die bekommen jedes einzelne Signal und die nehmen natürlich auch unser PGM, also unser Basisignal, das lassen sie oben drüber laufen. Aber am Ende kriegen die jedes Signal von uns, was aus unserer Sicht natürlich jetzt ein Abfallprodukt ist, weil wir das jetzt nicht mehr weiter verwenden, weil wir unser Basisignal haben und die internationale Produktion. Das hat schon sehr viel Sinn gemacht, so aufzubauen. Und jetzt ist ja auch in Planung, alles nach Frankfurt umzuziehen, was Sinn macht, als der eigene Standort ist. Und dann muss man eben die Signale über eine fette Leitung nach Frankfurt leiten.
Das sollte rund um Frankfurt mit dem Knotenpunkt da kein Problem sein. Aber ist denn das eine Problematik, weil Schiedsrichter ja wahrscheinlich andere Bilder brauchen, in manchen Situationen zumindest, als ZuschauerInnen?
Also, die bekommen die gleichen Bilder, wie wir sie auch bekommen.
Klar, weil sie kommen ja von Ihnen. Also sie produzieren es ja. Aber ich meine jetzt eben für Sie als Produzent, ich meine gewisse fest installierte Positionen, 16er hoch und so weiter. Das ist ja eine mehr oder weniger simple Kamera, die durchläuft. Aber gerade was so die Nahaufnahmen angeht, also fangen wir mal beim Videoschützrichter vorne an.
Was soll der Videoschützrichter? Grobe Fehler aufdecken. Da stellt sich mir die Frage. Grobe Fehler aufdecken, mache ich das besser mit 6 Kameras oder mit 25 Kameras? Wenn es um grobe Fehler geht, reichen 6. Da sagen die Schützrichter aber, jede Kamera mehr hilft. Und da sag ich, da fängt der, da fängt ein bisschen der Irrsinn an, weil dann bin ich am Ende nur noch Detektiv. Ich weiß, dass es schwierig ist. Und ich hätte mir gewünscht ganz am Anfang, dass das IFAB gesagt hätte, wir machen einen Standard. Für alle liegen, für alle die gleichen Regeln, weil die Spielfelder sind gleich, die Regeln auf dem Platz sind gleich. Nur beim Videoschiedsrichter haben wir unterschiedliche Regeln, weil da arbeiten wir von vier bis 30 Kameras. Und wenn da das IFAB gesagt hätte, wir arbeiten mit sechs Kameras und was wir da nicht erkennen, ist auch nicht falsch. Man kann jetzt eine andere Philosophie vertreten, das ist vollkommen klar. Das ist jetzt meine persönliche Meinung.
Ja, das verstehe ich gut. Aber wie gehen Sie denn damit um, dass der Moment des Video-Reviews ein extrem unangenehmer ist? Also im Starten hat man sowieso keine Ahnung, was los ist. Aber auch in der Fernsehproduktion hat man ja die Problematik, dass man nie weiß, wann ist der Check vorbei, wann bekommen wir überhaupt die Möglichkeit, eine Wiederholung zu zeigen. Man löst das jetzt bei der DFL mit einem Splitscreen. Also da sehe ich aber ehrlicherweise auf allen der Bilder einfach nur jemanden rumstehen, nämlich den Schiedsrichter. Und wenn wir Glück haben, dann macht er noch irgendeine Geste, an der wir handeln können, wie es geht.
Aber das ist aber auch gewollt, um zu zeigen, solange der Schiedsrichter da steht und nichts macht, sind wir noch in der Phase des Checkens.
Aber gibt es da keine Möglichkeit, diese Zeit fühlt sich extrem lang an für die Zuschauer? Und eigentlich, der DFB und DFL sind ja sehr gut da drin, das nachzurechnen. Im Check dauert das durchschnittlich dauert ein On-Feed-Review 84 Sekunden. Da würde ich jetzt sagen, das ist nicht so wahnsinnig lang. Da habe ich jetzt gerade schon mit der Formulierung meiner Frage länger gebraucht. Es fühlt sich aber am Bildschirm ganz anders an. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Regisseure in den Ühwagen, den brennt es ja auch unter den Fingernägeln. Die haben ja die Slow Mo's schon da, die sie zeigen könnten.
Die können die auch zeigen.
Könnten sie reinmachen? Also es ist eine bewusste Entscheidung, dass man erst wartet, was wird entschieden. Dann rollt der Ball wieder und dann hat man das Problem, ok, wann ist die nächste Unterbrechung, dass wir das machen?
Ja, wenn eine Entscheidung lange dauert, dann zeigen die auch die Slow Mo's, die sie zur Verfügung haben, schon. Also das ist ja vollkommen klar. Nur, wo wir natürlich auch ein bisschen aufpassen müssen, wir wissen ja auch nie, wie die Schiedsrichter entscheiden. Wenn ich jetzt also nehmen wir mal dieses Foulspiel von gestern. Erinnern Sie sich beim Spiel Barcelona gegen Mailand, wo es diesen Elfmeter gab? Da wird der Kollege, der Schiedsrichter zugeschaltet und dann sagt er ganz klar kein Elfmeter, saubere Grätsche. Und fünf Minuten später sagt er genau das Gegenteil, weil er noch eine andere Perspektive gesehen hat. So, jetzt stellen Sie sich das mal vor. Wir zeigen eine Perspektive, jetzt gehen wir von dem Fall weg, und da ist ganz klar so und so war es. Und der Schiedsrichter entscheidet anders.
Ist alles schon mal vorgekommen.
Ja, genau, aber es ist blöd, es ist blöd. So, also insofern, der entscheidende Punkt ist hierbei. Als ich 26 angefangen habe, gab es zwei Seiten einer Medaille. Die eine Seite war Sport. Ist die wichtige und die andere Seite Medien. Heute können sie es nicht mehr trennen. Weil die Schiedsrichter unsere Signale nehmen. Wir arbeiten Hand in Hand. Der Schiedsrichter, der Videobeweis ist Teil unseres Bildkonzeptes. Und muss es sein.
Es geht ja gar nicht anders. Und das ist der Punkt, wo die Trennung von Sport und Medien aufgehoben wurde. Und damit müssen wir heute klarkommen. Neben den ganzen anderen Themen, die wir auch schon besprochen haben, wie ein Fernsehsignal ein Barsignal aussehen soll und so weiter und so fort.
Es hat ja bisher auch noch nie Anti-Sportcast-Gesänge in den Stadien gegeben. Also da ist man ja jetzt vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt in der ersten Verantwortung. Jetzt ist mir aufgefallen, als ich mich mit der Sportcast beschäftigt habe. Ich habe mich mit den Unternehmen beschäftigt, wo sie in der Geschäftsführung sitzen, zum Teil ja auch in Beiräten sitzen. Und ich kenne die Realität aus Übertragungswagen. Es ist ein sehr männlich geprägtes Geschäft, immer noch die Übertragung von Fußballspielen. Wie verhindern sie denn, dass es da den sogenannten Male Gaze gibt, also eben diesen oft ein bisschen abwertend und objektivierenden Blick auf Frauen, der dann übertragen wird?
Also ich würde da erstmal, würde ich Ihnen widersprechen, dass wir mehr Männer dabei haben als Frauen. Liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass man schwere Kisten schleppen muss, auf die Tribünen, um die Kameras aufzubauen. Aber der Anteil an Frauen ist schon sehr hoch.
Können Sie ungefähr ein Prozentzahl sagen?
Nee, aber ich kann, also wenn ich jetzt gehe, zu der einen Firma sieht es so aus, gehe ich zu der Firma sieht es so aus. Aber auf den Gedanken wäre ich jetzt ehrlicherweise nicht gekommen.
Wie viele Regisseurinnen gibt es denn?
Da gebe ich Ihnen recht, da haben wir weniger. Aber da ist auch der Punkt, es gibt ja keinen Ausbildungsberuf, wo ich sagen könnte, ich kann das jetzt mal fördern. Das macht einer eine Zeit lang Slow-Mo, dann macht er eine Zeit lang Kamera, dann kennt er jemanden und sagt ihm, lasst mich mal bitte Regie machen. Also das ist schwierig. Da haben wir auch keine Ansätze, zu sagen, wir fördern das jetzt mal. Wenn Slow-Mo-Schulungen machen, wir selbstständig und dann machen wir Aushänge. Da ist die Durchsetzung schon eine ganz andere, dass wir da deutlich mehr Frauen haben. Aber also wenn sie mal auf den Übergestellplatz gehen, klar, sie werden mehr Männer als Frauen sehen, aber so würde ich es nicht formulieren.
Ich komme auch daher drauf, weil es hier auch eine Veränderung zu sehen gibt. Also was ja ein wichtiges Mittel ist in der Spielübertragung, nicht nur in den Zusammenfassungen, da hat es auch technische Gründe, ist der Gegenschnitt auf ZuschauerInnen. Und da hat es ja durchaus eine Entwicklung gegeben. Also vor ein paar Jahren, ich glaube, die WM 2014 wird da so in unrühmlicher Erinnerung bleiben. Da waren das eben mehrheitlich Frauen gerne auch leicht bekleidet. Und das hat sich ja schon mal verändert. Man nennt es total schlimmer Begriff, aber Candy Shot war der Begriff, unter dem das damals intern oft benannt wurde. Und das hat sich aber verändert. Und zum Beispiel auch dahingehend, dass mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, in den letzten, ich würde sagen, zwei Jahren sieht man auch ganz viele Kinder in den Gegenschüssen, ins Publikum. Gibt es denn da Vorgaben? Steht sowas auch in dem Regieleitfaden?
Also klar, wir wollen natürlich ein bisschen Emotionen zeigen. Und natürlich, wenn zwei Kinder, die nebeneinander sitzen, der eine ist rot-weiß angemalt, der andere blau-weiß, keine Ahnung was. Das ist schon gewollt. Aber auch wenn es passt. Und ich habe auch Spiele, wo ich dann denke, ich jetzt rufe ich gleich mal auf den Übergang an. Also wenn ich den Dortmundern der Leverkusen jetzt zum fünften Mal sehe. Manchmal muss man, die Regisseure sind ja auch Menschen und die sind dann auch während des Spiels in einem Tunnel. Und manchmal, wenn du die nachher fragst, ich habe mal ein Spiel gehabt, da hat er den Guardiola, glaube ich, zehnmal gezeigt. Da bin ich am Fernseher fast wahnsinnig geworden. Dann sagen sie Bescheid auf dem Ü-Wagen. Hört mal, Freunde, also in der Halbzeit, in der zweiten Halbzeit will ich den jetzt aber nicht zehnmal sehen. Dann sagen sie, ja wieso? Ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen. Die sind natürlich, das sind natürlich auch Menschen. Wir haben ja eben mal gesagt, 500, 700 Schnitte. Das ist schon eine Hochkonzentrationsaufgabe, wenn sie die ganze Zeit auf diese 10, 12, 15, 20 Monitore schauen, dann haben sie noch die Slow-Mo-Vorschauen und so weiter. Das alles, das muss man schon können und da muss man auch konzentriert sein. Das kann auch sein, dass man mal so ein bisschen in den Tunnel reinkommt. Also da muss ich schon sagen, ich habe da höchste Hochachtung für das, für das, was die Regisseure da Woche für Woche machen.
Aber gibt es denn da Vorgaben, also dass es jetzt eben nicht Zufall ist, dass man mehr Kinder sieht, weil generell muss man ja sagen, wenn man mal versucht, die Liegen voneinander abzugrenzen, dann sind ja die ZuschauerInnen schon mit der Kerne der Bundesliga, die Fan-Kurven, die lebhafte Stadionkultur.
Aber wir schreiben jetzt nicht da rein, wir wollen gerne ein 11- und 9-jährigen Jungen und Mädchen sehen, sondern da steht halt eben Zuschauerbilder, interessante Zuschauerbilder oder dies oder jenes. Wir können es ja auch nicht zu kleinteilig machen. Am Ende versucht wir ja auch ein Gefühl dafür rüberzugeben, was wir gerne sehen möchten. Neben, wie gesagt, noch mal, das wichtigste Spiel.
Das wichtigste Spiel, aber leider ist das Spiel manchmal so schlecht, dass man sich freut über die anderen Geschichten. Ich glaube, manchmal kommt dieser Gegenschnitt auf bestimmte Zuschauer, die man wieder sieht, auch daher, dass man hofft, dass man anhand derer eine Geschichte erzählen kann. Neulich habe ich eine Übertragung gesehen von einem Leverkusen-Heimspiel, da wurde die ganze Zeit dem äußeren Anstand nach ein besoffener Leverkusen-Fan gezeigt, der immer nur geschlafen hat. Wenn der jetzt aufgewacht wäre beim Tor, dann wäre es eine schöne Geschichte gewesen. Ist nicht passiert, deswegen waren es letztlich verlorene Shots.
Da sage ich Ihnen ganz ehrlich, da habe ich die gleiche Meinung. Am Ende machen wir auch Manöverkritik, deswegen machen wir auch diese Analysen und alle Spiele werden angeschaut und so weiter, um über solche Sachen zu reden. Aber der Punkt ist dabei, jede Woche 18 Spiele auf so einem hohen Niveau. Da stelle ich mich immer erst mal vor, meine Regisseure, und natürlich diskutieren wir intern solche Dinge auch. Natürlich gibt es dann auch mal am Montag einen Spruch auch Richtung unserem Kollegen, der das ganze Redaktionelle betreut und verantwortet. Das ist ja vollkommen klar.
Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht hier einen einzelnen herausnehmen. Für mich war eben nur die Frage interessant, weil ich eben auch gerade auch der Gegenschnitt auf Fan-Kurven, auf Choreos, das ist ja eigentlich schade, dass gerade dann, wenn Choreos gezeigt werden, eigentlich alle Lizenznehmer gerade in die Werbung gehen oder aus der Werbung gerade rauskommen.
Also wir haben einen sogenannten Rundown, der ist lang und der beginnt früh. Eigentlich weiß jeder, was wir wann machen. Aber das sind die Lizenznehmer. Es ist in deren Verantwortung und es ist am Ende auch deren Produkt, was sie verkaufen. Und insofern, wir können über bestimmte Dinge reden. Wir reden aber viele. Wir haben auch regelmäßig unsere Sitzungen, Absparen und so weiter und so fort. Abstimmungen. Aber so wie ich nicht möchte, dass mir jede Woche gesagt wird, wie ich meine Basis genau machen muss, so möchten die Kollegen und auch zu Recht nicht gesagt bekommen, wie sie ihr Produkt zu machen haben.
Das verstehe ich vollkommen. Jetzt kommen wir langsam ans Ende unserer Zeit. Sie haben mal in einem Interview gesagt, also unter anderem die Ü-Wagen, die fahren immer schon in der Nacht vor dem Spiel los, da sie nicht im Stau stehen, das Unfälle, keine Rolle spielen. Und Sie haben mal in dem Interview gesagt, das einzig größere Malheur, was passiert sei, sei gewesen, dass mal in Burghausen gab es mal ein Brand in einem Ü-Wagen. Da hatte man ein bisschen Probleme, das aufzufangen.
Nee, war ein bisschen anders. Also Burghausen, das war das einzige Mal, wo wir wirklich massive Stromprobleme hatten und sozusagen nicht senden konnten, weil der Strom nicht da war.
Ach so, war es kein Brand?
Nee, der Brand war in Danzig bei einem Länderspiel. Ein ZDF-Länderspiel und wir hatten über Nacht ein Brand in der Tonregie und wir konnten den Ü-Wagen nicht nutzen und haben dann versucht, am nächsten Tag, also am gleichen Tag versucht, aus Berlin einen Ü-Wagen nach Danzig zu schicken. Das war aber nicht zu schaffen, weil nicht komplett Autobahn, das letzte Stück, nach Danzig war. Und dann mussten wir eben das Signal der Polen übernehmen. Und Frau Müller-Hohenstein und Oliver Kahn sind dann nach Mainz zurückgeflogen und haben das Spiel dann sozusagen aus der Kabine mit polnischem Signal kommentiert.
Und man hat es eh nur an den Werbebanden gesehen.
Daran erkennt man es, genau. Dafür sind wir ja da.
Waren sie denn damals, weil sie ja auch mit UEFA und FIFA öfter eben schon zusammen gearbeitet haben, waren sie damals auch schon innoviert, 2008, als der Blitz eingeschlagen ist im IBU bei der EM beim Spiel Deutschland gegen die Türkei?
Ja, da waren wir auch dabei. Allerdings haben wir zu dem Zeitpunkt nur das gesamte FanTV-Thema gemacht. Wir haben die sozusagen in den Stadien bei allen Spielen das FanTV gemacht. Also das Programm und daraus aus solchen Dingen lernt man und verschaltet sich anders.
Ja, ich meine, es war ja interessant bei der EM jetzt in Deutschland, bei der Männer-EM. Wir sind in Frankfurt 160 Meter vom Stadion entfernt, der Blitz eingeschlagen. Außer einem lauten Knall und einem hellen Lichtblitz hat man nichts von der Übertragung gemerkt. Ist das dann auch unter anderem deshalb?
Ja, also ich erinnere mich an den Fall 2008, aber ich kriege jetzt nicht mehr genau zusammen, was da, wo der Fehler lag. Sicherlich fehlte eine Redundanz, über die keiner nachgedacht hatte. Das kann halt passieren. Und bei der WM in Katar hat auch kein Mensch gemerkt, dass das Spiel Deutschland-Japan auch nur mit 8 Kammer ausgemacht wurde, weil der Micha kaputt war. Das sind dann eben so Dinge. Es ist am Ende immer Technik und wir können uns es auch nicht erlauben, in jedem Stadion einen zweiten Ü-Wagen hinzustellen, weil es einfach viel zu viel Geld kostet.
Wie viel kostet so einen Ü-Wagen? Ich habe von vielen Millionen gelesen, 15 Millionen?
Ja, ne, zwischen 8 und 12. Zu meiner Wiegezeit habe ich ja noch den Auftrag für die WM 2006 für die FIFA Ü-Wagen vermittelt und verhandelt. Und da war es so, dass wir mit dem neuen HD-Ü-Wagen Köln und Hamburg gemacht haben. Die Verkabelung blieb da, teilweise auch die Kameras da. Und nur der Ü-Wagen fuhr zwischen Hamburg und Köln. Hier immer zwei Tage Unterschied. Und so war das Konzept mit allen anderen Stadien auch. Ein Ü-Wagen, zwei Stadien. Bei der Europameisterschaft jetzt 24 standen in jedem Stadion zwei Ü-Wagen, eine als Backup. Also da sieht man mal, wie sich das verändert hat, wenn Geld keine Rolle spielt. Aber an der Stelle, wir könnten uns das nicht erlauben, in jedem Stadion zur Ü-Wagen hinzustellen.
Jetzt gibt es ja, also gerade dann, wenn etwas nicht funktioniert, dann entstehen die oft magischen Momente, auch für die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer. Also wir haben die Kabelmuffe beim Spiel Werder Bremen gegen Schalke 04. War auf jeden Fall Saisoneröffnungsspiel und das Flutlicht fällt aus. Und da könnte man ja noch viele Beispiele nennen. Was sind denn so die Erinnerungen, die Sie an Ihre Zeit haben, bei Vorfällen, die dann in dem Moment natürlich wahnsinnig stressig sind, weil man versuchen muss, ein Problem zu lösen, aber wo man im Nachhinein dann vielleicht doch sagt, irgendwie auch werde ich es zumindest nicht vergessen.
Die eben besprochenen drei Spieltage und ansonsten, toll, toll, toll. Also von dem Klassik, bin ich immer froh, wenn es vorbei ist. Oder jetzt auch Bayer, Leverkusen, Leverkusen, Bayern, bin ich froh, wenn es vorbei ist.
Also sie meinten jetzt Bayer und Dortmund mit dem Klassik?
Und ansonsten, ich kann mich an viele Formel-1-Ubertragungen, weil wir auch Formel-1 viel gemacht haben. Oder auch Biathlon, WM, vielleicht auch Hanzentournee. Du bist immer froh, wenn es am Ende alles gut funktioniert hat. Weil du steckst nicht drin. Im Strom kann man immer was sein. Ja, also verlierst du eine Zehntel Sekunden den Strom, das ist ein Computer. Dann fährt der ab, dann rauscht der runter. Also insofern an das Beispiel, wo wir eben darüber gesprochen haben, wir waren im Polen, in Länderspiel und der Kollege rief mich morgens an und sagte, Jupp, ich wollte nur sagen, die Tonregie geht nicht, wir hatten heute Nacht ein Kabelband. Wir können hier nicht produzieren. Dann habe ich ihm nur gesagt, Sven, du weißt doch, mit solchen Dingen machst du keine Scherze und ruf mich für sowas nicht an. Und dann hörte ich nur, wie er sagte, Chef, ist kein Scherz. Und das willst du ehrlicherweise nicht erleben. Wir haben natürlich Notfallszenarien, mittelgroß klein, je nachdem, was ausfällt und so weiter.
Aber wie viele kuriose Dinge passieren denn? Also ich habe zum Beispiel ein Beispiel aus der Bundesliga der Frauen. Da hat einer der Kommentatoren einen Heizlüfter bei sich angesteckt am Kommentatorenplatz. Und die Steckdose war ganz offensichtlich nicht einzeln abgesichert, denn dann hatten für fünf Minuten beide übertragende Sender keinen Ton.
Also ich sage jetzt mal, wir sind natürlich so aufgestellt, dass wir eine USV haben, dass wir abgesichert sind, dass keiner...
Ja, dass sowas jetzt nicht passiert ist.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich unser Thema. Das gehört auch dazu, dass sie die hohe Qualität haben, dass sowas nicht passiert und dass sie alles mal durchgedacht haben. Aber ich komme jetzt auch neulich auf den Übergangsstellplatz und da sehe ich, wie ein Elektroauto mit unserem Strom verbunden ist. Da denke ich auch, das kann doch jetzt nicht sein. Und da komme ich jetzt hier hin als Chef und muss als Erstes sagen, du nimmst jetzt mal den Wagen von unserem Netz runter. Also es passieren so Dinge noch, aber ich hoffe mal, dass sie nicht so oft passieren. Und ich glaube, dass wir schon ein ganz gutes Netz aufgespannt haben, damit wir relativ hochwertig und sicher produzieren können. Bei uns arbeiten Leute, die schon länger als 20 Jahre in der Branche sind und die schon viel erlebt haben und dafür wissen wir, was passieren kann.
Und wie ist da das Feedback zum Beispiel von den internationalen Kollegen auch? Weil ich habe oft in der Recherche gelesen, dass die Sportcast sehr stolz ist auf ihre Qualität. Und das war auch durchaus manchmal zu lesen in internationalen Quellen. Aber jetzt würde mich mal interessieren, weil das ja auch eigentlich so mit das wichtigste Vermatungstool inzwischen ist. Da scheint noch ein Hebel zu sein, um so wirklich mehr Geld einzunehmen für die DFL. Und dann das Basis, das muss ja dann schon mal stimmen.
Genau. Also wir werden für unsere Produktionsqualität und Sicherheit immer gelobt. Weil jedes Spiel ist bei uns wichtig und jedes Spiel ist für die Lizenznehmer wichtig. Und sie werden nie ausschließen können, dass gar nichts passiert. Aber wenn dann ein Fehler passiert, dann müssen sie auch dann direkt beispielsweise ein Refit machen, also die Szenen nachspielen oder sonst irgendwas. Und das für uns gar keine Frage, dass wenn ein Fehler passiert, als erstes versucht wird, den Fehler wieder auszubügeln. Und dann gucken wir, woran es gelegen hat. Und das ist natürlich auch eine Art Produktversprechen für die Internationalen, dass auch nicht nur die Qualität, sondern auch die Sicherheit gegeben ist.
Und was glauben Sie? Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob Sie Ihren Vertrag nochmal verlängern wollen. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob Sie es selber nochmal wissen. Aber was glauben Sie, wie wird die Bundesliga-Übertragung in zehn Jahren aussehen? Was wird der größte Unterschied zu heute sein?
Ich glaube, dass nach wie vor das wichtigste Produkt das Live-Spiel sein wird, was ja schon seit vielen Jahren tot geredet wird, weil die jungen Leute angeblich ja noch nicht mal mehr fünf Minuten still sitzen können mehr. Also ich glaube, das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, dass sich in dem Thema des Wie was ändert, weil die Technologie fortschreitet, höhere Bandbreiten, andere Möglichkeiten zu schneiden, das Thema Automatisierung. Vielleicht kommt auch irgendwann mal das Thema automatische Kamera, wobei ich bei den 16er-Hochkameras mir nicht vorstellen können, dass die Schiedsrichter da möglicherweise zufrieden sind oder auch wir die Kameras gar nicht mehr brauchen, weil das automatische Absetzerkennung über Tricking geht. Also mit steigenden Rechnerleistungen werden sich, glaube ich, doch viele Dinge verändern. Ob am Ende das Bild ein anderes sein wird, in Nuancen vielleicht auch, ja. Und sicherlich hat sich auch die Anmutung beispielsweise der Tagesschau über 60 Jahre verändert, aber immer in solchen Schritten, dass wir es erst nicht wahrgenommen haben. Und so wird es möglicherweise auch kommen. Und vielleicht wird es eine Annäherung an eine Gemification geben.
Mehr Daten, live eingeblendet.
Genau. Aber wie gesagt, du musst dann am Ende mit deinen Nutzern, Konsumenten, Kunden, musst du im Austausch sein. Und das ist ja heute viel einfacher als früher. Ja, also ich glaube, dass noch viel Potenzial da ist, es noch interessanter zu machen. 2008 hat es eine Seite gegeben, die war von Castrol gesponsert. Da ging es nur um Daten. Die war total spannend, die Seite. Die war total spannend, die Seite. Und die Daten, wir haben die Daten alle. Wir haben noch viel mehr Daten.
Ach, wenn Sie die Daten an uns Journalisten rausgeben würden, dann würden Sie mich so glücklich machen. Aber das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema, nicht Ihr Ding. Vielleicht das als abschließende Frage von mir, könnte sich vielleicht auch passend zu unserer gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung, es geht ja wieder mehr so wieder aufs Individuum, die Perspektive grundsätzlich ein bisschen verschieben. Wir haben aktuell eine Draufsicht aufs Spiel. Und ich nehme wahr, dass immer, wenn wir eine vermeintliche Innensicht vom Spiel sehen, also egal, ob eine Refcam oder eine 8K-Kamera, die das alles hinten so blört, dass es aussieht, als wäre es ein Videospiel, das scheinen die Clips zu sein, die zumindest bei einer Zielgruppe, die jetzt nicht das Tagesschau-Publikum ist, ehrlich gesagt, sehr gut ankommt. Könnte das vielleicht sein, dass wir so eine Perspektivverschiebung haben und wir in zehn Jahren sagen, Mensch, früher haben wir ja wirklich viel aus der Eins gesehen, aus der Führungskamera. Und jetzt haben wir keine Ahnung, den Abstoß sehen wir jetzt immer aus der Brust des Torhüters.
Ich komme jetzt von der anderen Seite wieder. Also 90 Minuten ein Spiel gucken aus der Brust des Torhüters.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
So, deswegen glaube ich, dass im Mittelpunkt dessen, was der Fußball ausmacht, die 90 Minuten Spiel sind in der Draufsicht. Aber dass es immer mehr Features geben wird, ob jetzt live oder non-live, ob jetzt als Clip oder was auch immer. Ich glaube, dass wir uns mit den Dingen beschäftigen müssen. Aber die zentrale Frage ist für mich davor. Habe ich als DFL den Kundenkontakt oder hat der Lizenznehmer den Kundenkontakt? Und solange der Lizenznehmer den Kundenkontakt hat, sollte er am besten wissen, was er haben will. Und wir sind dann Dienstleister. Sollte die Perspektive sich ändern, müssen wir eine andere Denkweise haben. Das müssen wir dann aus einer anderen Sicht und aus einer anderen Verantwortung entscheiden. Dass wir uns mit den Themen auseinandersetzen müssen, um es sowohl so als auch da machen zu können, das ist ja gar keine Frage. Der Produktion ist egal, welches Geschäftsmodell dahinter ist. Ich muss aber immer springen, weil die Fragen gehen ja natürlich immer in zwei Richtungen.
Ja, das verstehe ich. Herr Nehl, Sie haben sich viel Zeit genommen. Vielen herzlichen Dank. Ich danke Ihnen sehr für Ihre Zeit. Die einzige Frage, die noch bleibt, ist, wie groß ist Ihr Fernseher zu Hause?
So groß definitiv nicht.
Er blickt hier gerade auf einen Fernseher. Wie viel Zoll werden das sein?
Ich kann es Ihnen auch nicht sagen. Ein Meter in der Diagonale. Also einer von uns. Genau. Das ist doch das Bild, was man zu Hause sieht. Das stimmt natürlich. Das ist mein Vergleichsmaßstab.
Über den Wechsel von 4 zu 3, 16 zu 9 konnten wir jetzt gar nicht sprechen. Aber das machen wir dann vielleicht hinter zweiter Sendung. Danke, Herr Nehl.
Sehr gerne.
Das war unser Gespräch mit Jupp Nehl. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, dann geht doch sehr gerne auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Da könnt ihr dieses Feedback loswerden und unterstützt doch sehr gerne den Rasenfunk. Denn alles, was wir hier machen, ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung da draußen. Und das gibt uns die Möglichkeit, eben auch solche Sendungen hier zu machen und unabhängig zu bleiben von all den verschiedenen Stakeholdern. Hier einmal das Wort im Gespräch, die es so gibt im Fußball. Also herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns schon unterstützt haben. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Chris1893, bei DIY-V, bei Thomas1848 und bei Oliver. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt, sondern sie haben sich auch als SupporterInnen registriert. Und so konnte ich sie hier nach dem Zufallsprinzip auswählen. In diesem Sinne, danke für euren Support. Es gibt noch viele andere Sendungen dieser Art, die ihr im Rasenfunk hören könnt. Klickt euch gerne mal durchs Tribünengespräch und abonniert doch auch gerne unsere anderen Feats. Wir sprechen über die Bundesliga der Männer, die Bundesliga der Frauen, die Zweite Liga Europäischen Fußball und über Nationalteams und Turniere. Also im Rasenfunk gibt es wirklich viel, viel, viel zu hören. Und das Ganze ist unabhängig produziert und ja, so wie ihr es gerade gehört habt, ausführlich und hoffentlich gut recherchiert. In diesem Sinne, bleibt uns gewogen, bleibt gesund. Bis bald, ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt, herzlichen Dank!